and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 144 today
we're gonna talk about simple living I'm
laughing cos like isn't that what we
talk about every single episode yes but
that's the the topic of today and so
well I don't have any follow up from
previous episodes now if you're
listening to this right now hopefully
you either listen to it or you're
watching you the YouTube video Jordan is
here recording both the video and the
audio today so if the audio doesn't
sound good I would say blame Jordan but
actually let's blame podcast Sean
because he's not here right now and he's
the easiest person to blame so hopefully
to defend himself and by the way if it
sounds better than we just know that
podcast Sean is irrelevant that's right
wait a minute dude I got some follow-up
man the tour was awesome yeah we're
gonna get to that during right here
right now we got a bunch of things that
are going on in the lives of the
minimalists but we're gonna save all
that for right here right now because we
have a bunch of questions to dive into
so those right here right now segment
toward the end of the episode we'll talk
about the tour we'll talk about my
health we'll talk about Ryan's haircare
and we're not talking about my hair okay
we won't do that I didn't put that in
the notes really did you no I don't
think so what's that let's dive into
these questions instead of voicemails
today we asked our Twitter followers
were at the minimalists on Twitter we
asked them to submit questions about
simple living and our first question
today is from Amanda Amanda Amanda asks
how do you define simple living man I
mean I can define simple it's all define
living so sometimes people ask what is
minimalism the thing I say about
minimalism is minimalism is the thing
that gets us past the things so we can
make room for life's most important
things now sometimes that word
minimalism is the perfect word because
it conjures up these images of like
stark white walls and empty warehouses
and owning very little and sometimes
that's intriguing
for folks because the average American
says 300,000 items in it so we're we're
steeped in stuff and minimalism feels
like the the antidote to that and I I
personally believe that minimalism is a
tool so it's part of the antidote too
it's a tool for us to to rid our lives
of the excess so we can live more simply
so if minimalism isn't the right word
for you maybe there are other words for
you sometimes people will just say
simple living or simplicity or
simplifying or deliberate living I mean
that's how I look at a man it is it is
using your resources intentionally yeah
making sure that your focus and your
attention is exactly where it where you
need it in your life to live a
meaningful life yeah and so if we're
talking about intention the opposite of
intention is is just going with the flow
and living without intention yeah and so
if you're living without intention I
think most of us are it's like when you
think of maybe meditation for example
the opposite of meditation is just
random thoughts you know it's the it's
excess thinking that's what we all do we
all just sort where our minds are filled
with thoughts oh yeah especially in the
the world we live in right now man I
mean how many impulses do we have a day
that I would love to see a study on that
like impulses that we have today versus
a hundred years ago yeah so 100 years
ago yeah you don't have social media you
don't have email you don't have
technology and that is just vying at our
attention it's it's all of it once our
attention so yes going with the flow is
is just reacting to every single impulse
yes and so simple living means we have a
finite amount of resources whether that
is your money
maybe it is your energy mm-hmm maybe it
is your attention yeah maybe it is your
time or your talent or your skill set
mm-hmm
these are all resources but they're not
infinite right and so we have to be
deliberate with the resources we have
but being unintentional means that we
just Britain we let whatever we let
anything in and we just accept it when I
had the big house in the suburbs it was
a relatively nice house but of course I
had to fill
every corner of the house and if there
was space I just let whatever in I
didn't do so with intention so
intentionality or simple living if I
were to define it is the removing of the
access so we can make room for what's
truly important I totally agree with you
you want to go into the next question
I do dan asks let's see our next
question here is from dan dan asks how
would you bring simple eating under the
simple living umbrella well keeping
healthy eating in mind so this is a
perfect segue I was actually gonna save
this part for though the right here
right now segment Ryan but it's a
perfect segment for me to talk about my
health and in ways I I've been on the
carnivore diet all month so a version of
what I might call I don't think anyone's
ever called at this with a modified
carnivore diet which is really strange
for me so let's have a quick discussion
about my thoughts and your thoughts on
different diets now you and I did an
entire podcast episode with our good
friend rich roll it's just called food
and we talked about healthy eating now
my partner Rebecca is also a dietician
and a nutritionist and so she really
understands healthy eating as well and
and the thing I've learned is that
healthy eating so back to to Dan's
question here what was the the question
specifically what did he ask
yeah Herc what his question specifically
was how would you bring simple eating
simple eating okay under the simple
living umbrella so so simple eating for
me is is more about so we just talked
about simple living has to do with
intentionality so maybe it's intentional
eating or intentionality when it comes
to the food that we consume now you know
this I used to be a fat bastard
we both did yeah I mean when we first
met we were in fifth grade in Ohio now
I'm just the bastard and I was literally
the fattest kid in school Ryan mm-hmm
and you were the second kid in school
that's that's why we became best friends
I think and well and we had shared
habits right and they were that we
certain those habits included a lot of
cheeseburgers yes a lot well a lot of
cheese related products just a lot of
cheese but she's been a lot of
constipation and our mmm preteen yeah
like it was literal
in you know in elementary school and now
we just have like a lot of figurative
cheese yeah well so so over the last in
my 20s I lost about 80 pounds I was
about 240 pounds and I'm probably 160 to
165 right now so I lost about 80 pounds
in my 20s by simplifying my diet cutting
out the access so there was some things
that I made sure I cut out they weren't
working well for me cheese or dairy was
one of them right so I found out I had a
soy allergy was making me break out like
crazy I think most people can do really
whoa I'm almost not my water over here
most people can do really well with soy
and I think you can do perfectly fine
with cylinder you can have a tofu steak
right now and and you wouldn't have any
problems like making me hungry Tofurky
thanksgiving dinner
remember that tofurkey that your ex-wife
made yeah she's poisoning me essentially
oh my eyes she was I have an allergy to
it makes me break out really bad
especially my scalp and so soy I have a
legitimate allergy to Dairy I don't have
an allergy to I just have a sensitivity
to that gluten I cut out of my diet and
then at one point oh you and I became
vegans for a year on it bet I won you
did win the battle oh me a dollar here
and you know what so we're filming this
right now it's about time dude you know
it's a shame that I have to call you out
in front of our millions of listeners
just so I could get a $1.00 bet paid to
me do you see this so here's what
happened $1 if you're watching us on
YouTube you can see the dollar here
there you go Ryan I'm gonna give you
this dollar because you lasted an entire
year as a vegan here's the irony how I
lost because of a month 11 I really
wanted some Greek yogurt and you're the
Greek dude why don't you hold on to the
dollar man no no no no it's much more
fun to talk about how you owe me a
dollar all right well it was it's a fake
dollar anyway don't you ever speak about
our first president that way not my
president does that work is it George
Washington yeah he's definitely not our
president Jon see it works fine anyway
when it comes to my
now I've made some significant changes a
couple years ago you can go back to our
health problems podcast episode 138 I
did the longest podcast I've ever done
with two of my doctors and we talked
about the health problems I've had now
this entire month we're actually
recording this the last day of July 2018
this entire month I've been on what I
would call the modified carnivore diet
and so what's that look like I eat five
items right now so I you know me I was
already I already had a pristine diet
yeah it was really good yeah so I had
cut out the gluten the soy the dairy the
sugar those are the four things I had
cut out before right
those were gone and so I had a really
good diet but for whatever reason it
wasn't working perfectly for me and so I
knew I needed to make a few changes the
beginning of this month I did a four day
fast this fast mimicking diet with a guy
named dr. Walsh to the Walsh protocol
and I did four days and after that I've
gone back to this I guess you would call
it the modified carnivore diet now
eating meat was really difficult for my
doctor recommended to two years ago
because I had been a vegan and then I
had been a pescetarian for a decade
after that right so we did our vegan bet
for a year the next nine years I was a
pescetarian only thing I ate was fish I
also got mercury poisoning from that
because I was eating so much fish and
nothing else well it was in combination
with your immune system too right yes my
immune system was compromised my gut was
compromised because I had c-diff and
then I also had these metal amalgams in
my mouth that were leeching into my body
so I'd mercury poison from both the fish
and the metal amalgams combine that
together it was a recipe for disaster so
this month after he won a four-day fast
I went back to I don't eat five things
right now and I've been doing this all
month those five things are meat so
mostly chicken and beef organic without
any of the hormones antibiotics yes yes
yeah none of the junk right sure and
also I've introduced some organ meats in
because that's really important and if
you go back to sort of the if you look
at the ancestral healthcare reminds me I
got like three tubes of liver worse I
need to give you yeah yeah and what cuz
I also do some supplements with with
beef liver as well and so because it's
really important to to eat the entire
animal if we're going to to eat the
animal
make sure that we're eating the parts
that are the most healthy for us yeah
you go back to our ancestors they would
throw away the stakes that you and I eat
now and and they're like they go
straight for the liver and the heart and
I had beef heart the other day and so
like so I eat meat that's number one
number two is I ate green so like kale
and arugula and an iceberg lettuce and
Robo char
yeah yeah so I greens okay leafy greens
leafy greens number three is I eat oils
and that's for me olive oil and coconut
oil in fact I usually walk around with a
few packs of olive oil in my pocket that
I just ordered these analy's from Amazon
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
but that just sees these little packets
of olive oil then yeah I walk around
with number four is coffee yeah well I
guess water would be of four and a half
right well I'm drinking water right the
only thing I drink is water and coffee
so and then number five a little treat
100% dark chocolate I've gotten as low
as I think 92% or 90% well but but I try
too and it's just like one little square
a day and that's like my treat and it
tastes amazing now that I've cut
everything else out yeah so let's talk
about what I've cut out of the diet for
me that's made my simple eating even
more simple so yeah so you're talking
about what you've cut out from your diet
this month the pristine diet that you
had before this right all right and so
here are a few things that I've cut I
removed fruit I removed so any fruit and
here's the weird thing
a month into this I no longer crave
fruit all in fact it doesn't even sound
good to me which it was always
surprising to me because I loved eating
pineapple and blueberry and I just I
don't crave it anymore the other thing
is I'm never hungry now like I'm just
like I've been hunger three times in the
last month so let's talk about that yeah
because if you like right now if you
didn't eat until four o'clock you would
be hungry I would yes so what is the
difference between like because there's
two different hungers that you're
identifying that I think so yeah so
there yeah so let's talk about when you
say you're not hungry
of course if you don't if you didn't eat
today you're gonna be hungry tomorrow
absolutely so what what is the
difference between the two hungers a
year there is
that same craving that there were I need
something to fuel me right now oh my god
I'm panicking kind of thing hangry is a
term that we often use it especially in
our culture where it's like I need
something immediately it's it's almost
like this impulse I don't feel that same
impulse anymore so the so maybe the
hunger what you're saying is you don't
feel the hunger anymore maybe is what
hangar be a synonym to what you're
talking about
I don't feel the hangar eNOS I feel
almost like a warning light come on now
I've been hungry specifically three
times this month so we're on day 31
right now for me and I've been hungry
three times twice had to do with getting
poor sleep and I was tired both of those
times so I think there's a good
correlation between lack of sleep and an
impulse eating right the other times
we're recording a podcast went a few
meetings we had to go to and I spent 21
or 22 hours without eating so I had
extended this accidental fast beyond the
limits of what I would usually go and so
my body wasn't like oh my god I need eat
something right now it was like hey
dummy
you should put some food in your body
here's the thing I've noticed now when
I'm eating these five items
I feel energy that I have never felt on
our last podcast or episode 142 actually
I talked about how like I haven't felt
this good since I was six years old
probably that's amazing and it's because
I was started being I was obese when I
was age 7 I doubled weight from age 6 to
age 7 it was right around the time my
mom started drinking heavily and so like
there's you know certain correlations
there but but ever since then like
there's been something and right now
this month my energy another resource we
just talked about yeah that is a
resource that I have not had a whole lot
of the last decade yeah but my energy
this month and when we were on tour the
last few weeks
everyone was commenting on it like wow I
can't believe you're still going through
this or or we had a super extroverted
day when we were down in Brentwood I'm
doing the Dave Ramsey show and stuff
like that was extroverted all day but I
was still able to cope with it right
I still reach my extroverted limits
because I'm an extreme introvert but I
have these additional reserves and I
don't have the midday crash that I used
to experience either also that one was
so real for me that midday crash the
eating some rice or some carbs so that's
the next thing I removed my eyes
I removed fruit right though that was
number one number two is starchy carbs
rice and potatoes like those things
aren't unhealthy but it's subjective and
those things aren't necessarily working
for me
and so what else did I remove besides
the fruit and the starchy carbs here's a
big one for me I removed eggs now I was
eating forward of eight eggs a day
always the healthy eggs you know the me
and just not factory farm kind of eggs
we're going out of my way to eat healthy
eggs but I have some sort of egg
intolerance I learned that because on
the 11th day of this month mhm
III said oh I'm gonna reintroduce that
one more thing eggs because you know
it's meat adjacent right so I brought
them in and immediately within an hour
crash I was messed up in the next day
and a half Wow and so eggs are gone
right now and the last thing I removed
are nuts and seeds I've never felt great
when eating a bunch of nuts and seeds
and now I'm sure I'll bring them back in
and maybe as a garnish eventually but I
you won't see me eat handfuls of nuts
and seeds anymore hmm and there are
several reasons that I've talked to my
doctor about for removing those but I
can tell you that by removing these
items it's like it's an extreme
elimination diet yeah but man I feel
good my energy is better I have less
need for sleep like I don't wake up
feeling tired anymore I'm sleeping
probably on average about one fewer hour
per night but I wake up more energized I
don't need the naps during the day as
much I've been asked a couple times this
month when they're really extroverted
days but I feel totally different also
my skin is so much better I feel good
wearing black shirts now because I used
to wear mostly grey shirts bigger like a
dark grey shirt because I always get a
bunch of dandruff on me I'm not getting
that this month maybe it's tiny bit but
not nearly what I was getting before
less itching now as a man you know your
your you know parts down low we often
they itch you know you could sort of get
the Al Bundy thing going you know I
don't never had that yeah but I don't
think we need to gender appropriate the
itch man I think why men in females
equally get itchy down there I don't
think so I think it's a stereotype for a
reason
is there a
about Al Bundy going this region I was
pants sort of scratching his balls all
the time yes I don't I thought that was
just a normal thing but this month
I feel like been totally fine without I
haven't felt like the need to like Oh
better Scratchy it's just guy I think
it's because my skin is better and it's
not feeling dry although yesterday I
tried to incorporate Brussels sprouts
back into my diet you know just really
splurge on some Brussels spray in and I
woke up this morning and I was like I'm
itchy down here and so like for me I
think I have I have a few things a few
problems with me one is I'm highly
sensitive to carbohydrates and I didn't
realize that number two is I think my
blood sugar spikes and dips much more
radically than other people so I'm not
recommending this diet for anyone else
I'm simply saying what has worked for me
well yeah I think what you're talking
about is it's a great example for Dan
dan is asking how can you incorporate
simple leading with simple living and
what we talked about earlier simple
living is living deliberately it is
finding out how you can bring things
into your life or how you can use the
resources you have in your life in a way
that gives you the most meaningful life
and where you're describing right now is
this process that you have gone through
you've worked so hard you have years and
years I mean it started back in 2014
when the health problems really started
coming down on you for the last four
years did you have been doing
elimination diets you've been meeting
with different doctors you've been
listening to different health podcasts
you've done so much to basically bring
you to this point right now yeah where
you have figured out exactly what you
need yes for your own personal diet
which makes you feel the best it is a
perfect synecdoche for the rest of our
minimalist lives yeah and so I but also
realizing how subjective it is because I
look at my partner Rebecca she is one of
the healthiest people I know her diet is
almost the exact opposite of mine she is
pretty much a vegetarian she'd some eggs
occasionally she'll occasionally eat a
piece of meat if she's sort of forced
into it but she also looks like she
stepped off the cover of a like women's
health magazine she's super fit she does
you a SoulCycle and she
you know I CrossFit exercise and and and
so her life is super healthy with a
radically different diet from mine and
so then the question becomes like what
is the appropriate diet for your life
now let me tell you three things that
I've experienced since being on this die
this one number one is the more energy
already talked about that
number two is way way way less
inflammation I don't feel as a key hmm
as as I as I did before right I used to
feel so achy and sort of creaky and I
just assumed my well I'm 37 now I'm
getting old mmm well maybe it's not
about getting old maybe it's about
fixing that inflammation yeah I don't
feel flamed anymore and man that's
amazing man it and just to your point
like this is this is the diet that you
have found for yourself right this is
not something you're saying everyone
needs to do this now no I what I'm
saying is you need to figure out what
works well right you and sometimes with
minimalism and anything else it's
eliminating all this other stuff and
then slowly bringing things back in yeah
and it's hard work to man and absolutely
it is I mean for years you've been going
through different diets and doctors man
and and and it's it's funny to the point
where I am I'm so happy that you're
feeling good and healthy there is a
piece of me though that is like scared
of like oh [ __ ] yeah like I hope that
this lasts I hope it isn't like because
how many times have you taken you know
ten steps forward and then six steps
back right and and I I I'm cautious that
way but I'm also so I'm gonna do this
for 90 days so there's an in and in game
here then I'm gonna do my blood work and
compare it to the 90 days before so I
have some markers and figure out okay
that now what do I need to adjust what
do I need to bring back in what do I
need to supplement what do I need to
change because once you get an answer
doesn't mean that's the answer for the
rest of your life right right it means
this and once you get an answer it's an
answer for you yes right it's not an
answer for everyone else no yeah and so
you can maybe tweeze out an ingredient
or two of what I'm doing
no the few other things that have helped
me out or that I've noticed this month
I've significantly increased libido and
and sexual performance like it's been
really great like Bex is and my sex life
went from life
a 10 to a 12 and I feel really great
about that but also just my overall
energy level and mental clarity I feel
clearer now than I have before I don't
feel that same fog or or I don't feel
lethargic like I used to
and there's a certain clarity that I
wasn't getting before that is lost and
so that's my you know my thoughts on
sort of this carnivore diet but also on
simple eating and I'm willing to change
it if I don't get the results and I
think that's the important thing to
mention absolutely man um let's move on
to this question from Gino how can I be
a minimalist with a roommate how do I
make my roommate a minimalist now that's
how much Gino is asking well I you know
what but sometimes that question could
be can be translated that way and
sometimes that's actually what they mean
right right yeah and you know what that
it's it's an aspiration like I want
everyone else to be just like me no
actually we don't want everyone else to
be just like us because that'd be a
relatively boring life right so I think
the first thing to think about here I
object slightly to the question because
it presupposes that you can't have a
roommate if you're a minimalist right
yeah well yeah and so I think about I
mean I think about yours and mariah
situation or vexes in my situation with
Ella and and I think it has to do first
off with with coexisting with other
people and appreciating them for who
they are yeah so let's talk about
minimalism or no minimalism yes how do
you be a good roommate ah how do you
have a good roommate yeah so you go out
of your way to add as much value as you
can you go out of your way to support
your roommate to respect your roommate
to appreciate the differences and if you
act like that I mean that's the Golden
Rule man you treat someone how you want
to be treated
so if you go out of your way to do these
things for a roommate the hope is is
that the roommate is going to
reciprocate all of these amazing things
that you've done for them and the same
thing goes with minimalism it's it is
something where if you have a roommate
and you go to them and you say hey there
are a few expectations I would like to
you know to ask if you would be willing
to do right um you know the common area
is let's keep them
with the kitchen you know let's let's
keep that stuff clean and if you have
done all that upfront work of being
supportive with your roommate and
showing them that you respect them you
respect the differences even at that
point where you appreciate the
differences well your roommate is
probably going to be probably going to
be okay with with making these I think
one comp compromises but agreeing with
these community rules essentially yeah I
mean there's no way that you can go to a
roommate and say hey look I'm a
minimalist that means you should be a
minimalist too we've got we've got too
many couches in here we got too many
tear we got too many silverware I mean
that is that's the wrong way to approach
a roommate the best way again is to it's
to show support and then ask for ask for
support back now sometimes like I had a
roommate that they don't give you the
support back sure no matter how much you
support them and in that case well I had
to go find a new roommate yeah I think
that's the keys we're also not stuck
realizing that like this might be the
ideal roommate situation for the next
month the next six months the next year
yeah but in it doesn't mean you're gonna
be roommates in perpetuity
very rarely or two people roommates for
the rest of their lives right so if
you're feeling overwhelmed you feel a
bit of despair despair says something
about your future realize that the
future can change and so maybe this this
roommate situation is necessary right
now but you can change it as well and so
you don't need to be with that roommate
forever
and maybe it just means finding another
place where you can be by yourself or
finding another roommate who's going to
share your similar values but with that
said you're gonna you're never gonna
find the perfect roommate who's exactly
like you who shares the same exact
identical preferences as you yeah
mariah is by far the best roommate best
romantic part I mean this is like the
one of the best relationships I have
ever had in my life and there are still
nuances that I that it's my problem not
hers where there are preferences that I
have that I have to I have to look at
and say hey Ryan this is your preference
that's okay that this is your preference
but do not force your preference on
Mariah if anything if it's really
bothering me that much
I will go to Ryan I will say hey I've
got this one particular preference that
I really would love to have your help
on
and she's so awesome that she is usually
willing to to help me out but you know
even if there is something where it's
totally ridiculous if it's totally
absurd that I'm that I'm asking and and
she points that out no Ryan that's
ridiculous well that's where that's
where it's my turn to to give it makes
me think about the us box yes
so another you know so the us box we
talk about this a lot where with every
relationship there is an us box and
you've got to look at how often am i
giving to that us box if you're just
taking from that us box well then guess
what you are a your succubus no one
wants to be a succubus yeah but if
you're giving to that us box and the
other person is giving to that us box
well usually that makes for a really
really good relationship and sometimes
giving to that us box it means not
putting my preference first and and I
mean obviously Mariah and I put each
other's preferences first as much as we
can but there's some times where it just
doesn't work I'm trying to think of an
example right now I can't think of
anything because we get along so
freaking well but but well I've got some
because I'm so neurotic yeah go for it
with me and back so so yeah what's a
preference you have that actually I know
a huge one dude you've got a kid yeah
that is the biggest dude out of all of
so was me Josh his brother Jerome we had
another friend it was the four of us who
always hung out in high school and I am
the last of the four to have a kid and I
really really thought it was gonna be
Josh because his preference was so stuck
on
I don't want children dude this yeah
this was um this is something that up
until you met Beck's
right it was a deal breaker yeah and
even when I met backs it was like oh
this is totally reframing
the way that I think about the world mm
because I mean you have some options
here right it's in order to be a good
roommate or a good partner or yeah when
I think of a roommate you really just
talk about living partners because you
are a partner in living and I would get
Mariah's my roommate yeah she's also my
romantic partner she's my like spouse
equivalent yeah yeah that's the the the
Jonathan Jonathan Franzen term
and and so you know when I think about
when I think about roommates or partners
or anyone in which we are in a
relationship with where we go wrong is
when we think about me and we're not
thinking about we amen dude I am so bad
at that man and and so one thing that
catch myself all the time
Oh like we're moving I'm moving and I'm
like no no we are moving right it wasn't
it like we were talking about moving to
LA the way I phrased it on the show
sounds like Mariah wasn't coming it's LA
we were tweeting you I are your partner
coming with you or that yeah and so for
me is so important one of the things
that we do is we should have to have
shared preferences and in the sense that
like if I want to bring something new
into the house and we both need to agree
on that thing otherwise it doesn't come
into the house at all
now that is an ideal relationship but
also means I have to sacrifice something
I would really like to have this widget
or this thing that I would get value
from but if we aren't gonna get value
from it's gonna get in the way of
someone else's preferences then we agree
to not bring in a house and the opposite
is also true if max wants to bring in
you know some painting that I don't like
or something we both need to agree on it
but here's the nice thing about that it
keeps the house aggressively simple
there's far fewer things to clean but
the things we do have in there we both
really enjoy so we're not having these
unnecessary disagreements or arguments
about those things there's also some
words that we won't use like I won't use
the word hate I hate that idea I also
won't attack the other person yeah and I
think that's that's really important
never attack the the person or even
their actions instead I will share my
preferences amen dude you know earlier I
with this question I said something
about setting some expectations that I
mean that is in an ideal world that
sounds right just go with your roommate
and set expectations but you don't
literally want to go to your roommate
and say hi I have expectations I'd like
to set with you right like that is gonna
put it off on on that's gonna start off
on the wrong foot with that conversation
so when having that conversation to your
point
you're talking to someone it is it is I
always talk about the I versus you so if
I'm saying something negative or not
negative but if I'm asking someone else
to correct something they're doing I
will try to put it on myself as much as
possible so for example hey Josh I
really appreciate our relationship you
have been my best friend you know since
the fifth grade and for that I am so
grateful for I've got this problem
though man where I need to have ten
glasses of water on this table and I
know that that's a lot of glasses of
water for you and I really want to
respect your preferences but I really
really need those ten glasses of water
on this table while we record a podcast
would you be willing to help me out with
my problem is there anything that we can
do and maybe it's not ten glasses maybe
it's five glasses I'm obviously using
something really arbitrary and
non-existent right now right but but the
whole point is is that having a
conversation with someone especially
when you're trying to get them to change
their actions or to change their
behavior you have to a make it their
decision and you have to put all of the
all of the the guilt or the negativity
whatever it is that you're projecting
you've got to put that on yourself
because if it is a indeed a projection
then you want to avoid projecting that
anyway because really what you're doing
is escalating in that situation the
opposite is also true when I think about
quite often in past relationships I've
been in or even in my current
relationship to a much lesser extent is
yeah is everything okay is everything
okay because we hide sometimes when we
have some sort of problem you can see us
someone's features quite often not me
because I don't wear my heart on my
sleeve as much as most people but but we
go to people is everything okay you sure
everything's okay well there's a book by
a friend Colin right it's called some
thoughts about relationships right and
one of its it's a bunch of policies
about relationships it could be intimate
relationships friendships roommates
whomever and one of the the policies he
has it's called the iíll tell you policy
hmm if something is wrong it is my duty
to tell you about that and that way I'm
never going around questioning backs
where are you sure everything's okay
yeah are you worried about something not
telling me is there something that
you're not telling no because we have
this policy and it would be actually I
would be disingenuous of me and it would
be a lie of omission if I didn't tell
her that something was wrong I would be
lying if I didn't tell her something's
wrong because we have this policy
between each other the I will tell you
policy has made me be more upfront about
my feelings and also the issues I have
one last thing that has helped me is
sitting down and and this is the last
thing I will recommend here for Gino is
have a conversation with your roommate
and don't say here are the expectations
I have just say hey what are 10 things
you would like to see me improve yeah if
you sit down and say what are 10 things
that I can improve mmm do you think the
person is not going to turn around and
say have one of 10 things I can do to be
more supportive because Ryan when you
and I were we were roommates for 13
months we first move out to Montana we
move to that cabin in little nowhere
four months than me you and Colin right
we all lived in the the same
asymmetrical house and we started our
publishing company together we lived
there for seven months and you two were
the two best roommates I'd ever had
mainly cuz you're the only roommates
ever had and I I know it's hard I'm
really difficult to live with that's an
expectation I set with anyone but oh you
don't know that but I it's an
expectation I set yeah here's why I'm
really difficult to to live with I have
I have OCD you have certain preferences
and both of you even though you had
different preferences you are really
respectful of my preferences absolutely
well because dude if I want you and
Colin to be respectful of my preferences
I have to respect your preferences I
mean it's that's the only way it works
man I agree
you know what Mariah and I do every
every if it's not once a month it's once
every other month but I will ask her
what's one thing just start with one
thing what is one thing that I can do to
like make this relationship better yeah
and she might say oh you know set me
with a better expectation of what time
you're gonna be home after podcasts or
maybe it's just one thing and then in
turn yeah and then you know I can say
hey well that's great I'm gonna do this
and then she'll say is there anything I
can change and you know if there is
great if not but but yes I love that
idea man like this is this is powerful
man to go to your roommate or any
relationship and say what can I do to
make this relationship better and I
think I think the reason I bring up 10
at first is because you're gonna realize
this probably there probably aren't
10:30 right and they'll be grasping and
you'll realize you're actually closer to
the same page than you thought you were
now here's the other thing if you have a
list of 43 things that your roommate can
change then maybe it's about you you
can't change the people around you but
you right change the people around you
it might be time to get a new room yeah
no doubt okay so I totally let you off
all right or never I should Jenny's
question Ginny asks what's the one thing
we can do that has the biggest impact on
achieving a minimalist lifestyle so is
there one thing oh yeah I objected the
question because I wish there was one
thing that you could do that would like
now I'm a minimalist
different for everyone why I used to
play basketball right and so when I
played basketball there wasn't one thing
that would win the game for us it was
playing offense it was shooting well his
free throws it was playing defense it
was ball control it was managing the
clock correctly it was assists that was
steals there were all of these different
things that you could do in order to win
the game and I don't like this because
what you're really looking for is a
shortcut
yeah the thing that I will tell Jenny
here is there are no shortcuts but there
are more direct paths and so I mean if
she's struggling Ryan if you're
struggling to live a minimalist
lifestyle maybe the question is what is
the one thing I can do next and Greg
McEwan's book essentialism he talks
about how the word priority was a
singular word until the 20th century and
now Ginny is saying well maybe I have a
hundred priorities what's the one thing
I can focus on know you can still focus
on the hundred things but what is the
priority meaning what is the one thing
priority literally means the one thing
yeah what is the one thing you can focus
on now that is going to get you the most
bang for your buck what's the most
appropriate thing so going with the
basketball analogy it depends on the
basketball team right like there might
be one thing that you know could have
helped the Cleveland Cavaliers
won the championship yeah I mean Junior
Smith knowing what the score was would
have helped and gay right exactly but
then you go to a different team there's
one thing that's there's one thing a
different thing that might help out
another team so Jenny to your question
it's not what's the one thing this over
our arcing you know question for
everyone like what is this one thing
that could make people a better
minimalist the question is is what is
the one thing for you that can help you
be a better minimalist like going back
to those priorities man I always when
people tell me they've got 10 priorities
and I don't know what you want to focus
on it's like what you give up got one or
two options you could put them all in
the Hat pick one out or you can just go
to the first thing that you've written
down on your list yeah but you do have
to choose well let me give you some
simple tips here this might help at
least move you in the right direction
the first one is ask yourself a question
how am i life be better with less and
that'll help you identify like what is
the one thing for me for me initially it
was finances for you it might mean I
have more time for my family I have more
time for creating I have more time for
my hobbies I have more time to
contribute to my community I have more
time for my relationships I have more
time to focus on my health what is the
thing that is important to you and by
asking that question you'll be able to
figure out how do I move forward now if
you want some simple tips I mean you
could try the 30-day minimalism game
it's a new month and so you partner up
with someone we'll put a link to that in
the show notes but basically how that
works is you just partner up with a
friend a family member a co-worker on
the first day of the month each get rid
of one item second day the month two
items third day the month three items
starts off really easy gets you that
momentum that you need and so momentum
is might be the one thing for you right
and if you because if you're stuck
you're not moving anywhere maybe you
need some momentum we'll start off with
30-day minimalism game and get you going
in the right direction by the middle of
the month it gets way more difficult
because it's day 15 you're like oh crap
I got to get rid of 15 items day 20 I
got it rid of rid of 20 items and then
tomorrow after of 21 and so whoever goes
the longest wins if you both make at the
end of the month you've both won because
you've gotten rid of about 500 items and
then if you really want to get extreme
with it if you're someone like Ryan
maybe something like a packing party so
Ryan packed up everything that he owned
in over 21 days unboxed only the items
he needed so he pretended he was
and as he pretended he was moving
he realized that most of the stuff he
owned was just owning him because well I
mean you know Ryan as you were going
through that you're like I don't even
remember I can't remember what's in most
of these boxes and and if that's too
extreme for you but you still want
something a little bit extreme do a
packing party with one room when's the
last time you used all those cosmetics
or the weird stuff that's growing mold
below the sink in your bathroom right do
a packing party for your bathroom do a
packing party for your kitchen and why
do you have 30 coffee mugs that say
number one grandpa on them are you
actually gonna use those things yeah
it's it's man I wish there was just this
easy answer to be like dude this one
there's this one simple trick on being
an awesome minimalist I mean if there's
one trigger to live deliberately yeah I
mean that's that's the one trick all
right we ready to move on to Farrah
let's do it all right a next question is
from Fira how do you balance the thought
between live your life as it is right
now and worrying about the future my
anxiety about the future often makes me
not enjoy the life I currently have so
we just did an episode on anxiety Ryan
yeah and this question is appropriate
because what Fira is trying to balance
is what is going on in my life right now
yeah and then I'm also worried about the
future now you can think about the
future sure without worrying about the
future I think there's two different
things now
Fira here just by thinking about the
future is sort of presupposing and no
matter what she does to think about the
future she's gonna be worrying about the
future now I want to live a life that my
future self is going to be proud of so I
want to live a life that is congruent
well right now my daily actions today
are congruent with the person I want to
be a year from now five years from now
ten years from now and so that way I'm
not gonna be worried about the future
I'm going to be anticipating the future
for what it is and living in the moment
for me means making sure that I'm
congruent there's some sort of
congruence between the person I want to
be and the actions I take right
yeah so I mean step number one sounds
like fira has got to get clear on what
her values and beliefs are yeah because
I mean ultimately when when I think
about living a meaningful life when I
think about you know what is happiness
and I say happiness as a not as in like
endorphins hitting my head and being
happy but living a meaningful life and
Happiness longer-term well-being
yeah is interchangeable for me it's when
my short term actions align with my long
term values and beliefs and if I'm not
clear on those values and beliefs well
then I'm gonna be lost until I figure
out what those are so step number one is
yes figure out what those values and
beliefs are I mean I can't I tell you I
mean how many times have we we talked
about that I can't tell you how many
mentoring students I've had and like
that's where we start getting clear on
their values and beliefs because that is
the compass that's that is that is the
guide for what you should take action on
every single day and when something is
off balance when you're not able to live
in the moment that compass really helps
yeah and I think your your beliefs need
to be anchored in your values because if
not the the so our beliefs of the past
that get us to the destination the
destination being the values and quite
often we might have a bunch of beliefs
we don't know why we believe them mm-hmm
and that becomes a problem as well where
our beliefs are often someone else's
beliefs and we don't know how we got
there or actually where we're going
won't know how we got on that path that
belief and we don't really know where
it's taking us and so I think it's
really important to start with those
values and then you figure out how do I
get to to where I'm going
absolutely man that another tool that I
will recommend for Farrah is your
calendar like this for me is so
important because the calendar helps me
plan ahead for you know not just staying
on top of my adult responsibilities but
also for my free time for for one more
recording a podcast but having having
everything scheduled out and being able
to know where I'm supposed to be when
supposed to be there that helps me to
live more on the moment because I'm not
so paranoid but did I forget something
today I do like sometimes I'll wake up
in the morning and I'm like where am I
gonna be today and I'll poke the
calendar and I'm like oh I don't have to
be anywhere today oh that's right yeah
like and I can look at that and I can
instantly let that anxiety go and you
realize you're doing what you're
supposed to be dancing that's why you
let the anxiety go exactly and then the
other thing too man this is a I mean I
would recommend this for anyone but for
me man like you and I were just talking
about before this podcast the how Marie
and I have been doing this budget over
the last couple months and how it has
affected you know different things in
our lives but what I'll say man is like
knowing where every dollar is gonna go
and having a plan for that dude that
takes off so much anxiety not just for
the month but for retirement for
everything else man like so so really
you're thinking about the few yeah don't
worrying about exactly man so maybe like
this is a this is my way of saying Farah
you need to find tools to use in your
life that help you to plan for the
future
so that you don't have to constantly be
worrying about what is happening in the
future yeah and so some of those tools
are using your calendar effectively and
scheduling as much as you can including
some of the things that I schedule our
time just to mess around on YouTube for
an hour yeah I did this last night
actually by the if I had my workday done
and so from 7:00 until 9:00 p.m. I
watched unnecessary YouTube videos and
come and I felt good about it because I
had planned for it ahead of time and so
I didn't I didn't feel like well should
I be doing something else right now no
this was the best use of my time because
I had planned for it accordingly now of
course you can over plan you can plan a
bunch of nonsense for your day you have
to be honest with yourself when you're
using these tools you have to use them
effectively a hammer is a tool what if I
used it to just beat Jordan over the
head with it he's not gonna be happy
about it and our videos would suck but
do you know it's funny like we planned
vacations yes and like vacations are
these times it's our
ourselves permission to go somewhere and
pretty much do whatever we want with
that time that we have set aside and you
know planning a week vacation is is is
great but planning a little our vacation
is great do we all have to we all have
to veg you know minimalism is not about
staying productive 24 hours a day no
it's not about constantly be working
towards this mass of making a dent in
the universe get things done minimalism
is about it's about keeping our keeping
ourselves sane in this insane world that
we live in right and and yes like part
of for me even though I'm a huge
extrovert man like I still need to veg
out and Mariah and I we will sit and
watch you know stupid reruns of well
they're not stupid they're hilarious of
you know Seinfeld or the office or
whatever it may be but but yes there's
no shame in there's no shame in vegging
out there's no shame in watching
unnecessary YouTube videos the only the
only time where I feel shame when I do
that stuff is when I know I should be
doing something else but if you schedule
the time to do it yeah there's no reason
to feel guilty the reason that you feel
anxious quite often is because of the
many distractions that are out there
there's this fear of missing out because
we're constantly bombarded by endless
messages yeah do this do this do this
and we feel like we're missing out and
that produces anxiety now you can reduce
the number you can filter out the number
of inputs if we get 500,000 discrete
inputs every day there's no way that we
can filter through all of them but what
we can do is put up some walls some
barriers we can remove the social media
apps from our phone yeah we can agree to
check our email once or twice a day at
scheduled times we can agree to not
spend more than an hour a day watching
television we can agree to use the
calendar we can agree to use a budgeting
app like every dollar you we can agree
to use for me I use a today list now
that's a do list a today list to really
figure out what my priorities are that
eliminates the many
distractions that I have if we get rid
of those distractions the anxiety level
decreases dramatically absolutely one
other thing don't confuse ephemeral
happiness with long-term well-being hmm
another essay from our friend Colin
right it's up on our website right now
it's called eudaimonia we'll put a link
to it in the show notes it's a different
kind of happiness quite often we think
of happiness as as this momentary burst
of pleasure yeah I've got a
five-year-old daughter and Ella is
always in the moment they're kids
five-year-olds especially are really
great at being in the moment they don't
don't worry about you know retirement
right nothing I want to worry about it
they don't have to think about yeah
right yeah and so they don't do much
thinking in fact if I asked her what she
did yesterday the answer is almost I
have no idea I don't know I don't know
because they're so focused on the right
here and right now and that can be great
as long as you are also thinking about
the the future and in the future
consequences that's why as adults we
have fully developed frontal cortexes we
have to think about both and so this
essay eudaimonia really talks about
balancing out that short term a static
pleasure mmm with long term well-being
yeah I'm less concerned now with the oh
my god I have to feel excited in every
moment what a better expectation is so
bad and that's why kids have tantrums is
because they don't have that as soon as
they lose that in the moment excitedness
it's oh my god I'm freaking out yeah
instead let's worry about long term
well-being well-being in the moment but
also does this lead to my future
well-being and that term is called
eudaimonia yeah and so take a look at
that essay we'll put a link to that if
you're watching this on youtube you can
probably see it on the screen as well
alright Ryan our next question is from
Mimi Mimi asks how do you break the
strong attachment to your stuff it's
easy just become a minimalist
next question you know what I thought
about this and when people are working
with iron right like if they're a
hammering iron and you know forming it
into something new or they need to break
off a piece the easiest way to break a
strong piece of iron is to make it less
strong you have to heat it up in this
case right in order to make that
attachment or to make that that piece
more malleable and I started the wrong
way when I first embraced minimalism I I
start with my mom sentimental items the
hardest piece of the iron right I like
took the iron and try to break it over
my knee right and it was painful to do
that so I don't recommend starting with
the most painful items don't hurt
yourself
right so I think the easiest way is to
find the weakest attachments first if we
all own a bunch of stuff that we're not
using and we can all agree that most of
the things that most people own myself
included in my 20s most of it over 90%
of the things I own probably were junk
now I pretended they added some sort of
value to my life but they really were
just excess they were in the way they
weren't adding any real value to my life
but the reason I couldn't let goes
because I had some sort of strong
attachment to it but there were some
things where I could rationalize very
easily I didn't feel that emotional
attachment to it so start with the
easiest things first you get that
momentum and so you can go to your
closet I think most people can start
with their closet or they can start with
their junk drawer or they can start with
their kitchen cabinets and they can go
in there and say what is the thing in
here that I haven't worn the last year I
haven't used in the last year and I'm
not going to use within the next year
that's a derivative of our 9090 rule
eventually you can say have I used this
in the last 90 days am I going to use it
in the next 90 but to develop that to
define the weak attachment what's the
thing I've used in the last year I bet
you there are some things that are still
in a box from the last time that you
move maybe it's in a basement or attic
or a closet somewhere maybe you don't
even know what's in that box and you
start there and you realize I actually
pretty weak attachment to this and you
give yourself permission to let go of
the weak thing right because it's
already but the iron has already been
heated for that and so it's easier to
break apart and from there you realize
like oh there are other weaker
attachments and you develop the strength
that you need to let go and letting go
becomes a muscle that you strengthen
over time until you get to the point
where you are a minimalist you your
advice even though you said it in jest
is actually good advice it become a
minimalist meaning strengthen your
letting go muscle yeah
becoming a minimalist I mean that's much
easier said than done but that's you
know what you just described is kind of
the process of becoming a minimalist I
think one of the like the biggest things
that I do to help me not get attached to
stuff is I have stopped bringing stuff
into my life that I know I'm going to be
attached to like I started thinking
about uh when Mariah and I go on
different vacations I mean we've been to
Europe we've been to Tokyo we've been to
Germany we've minused some really
awesome places I've got nothing no Josh
no tchotchkes from any of those any of
those trips uh you know partly because
like I don't want to have to make room
for it on the airplane right so I mean
like there's that there's that motivator
there but but owning so on our last trip
you you're talking about that someone
tried to give me a thing that I actually
was gonna get some value was a book
right we were down at Dave Ramsey's
compound I said hey would you be willing
to mail one of those to me because my
bag the packed one bag that you and I
both use has exactly enough space for
the things that I'm going to use during
my trip yeah now could I cram a book in
there yes a it's gonna make it heavier
which is a perfect metaphor for bringing
new stuff into our lives we have to
think about these things actually weigh
us down now you see that when you're
traveling you may not see it when you're
just storing that extra widget or the
the tchotchke from Germany or wherever
your store in your house but in a way it
does weigh you down right yeah I mean
the bag too it's I mean it is a it's a
limitation that that we give ourselves
when we're on tour when we're traveling
we have our bag there are the things
that fit in the bag and anything that
doesn't fit in the bag well it doesn't
go in the bag but it's also a metaphor
for the rules and the limitations we put
on ourselves in life you brought up you
know the different roles that we go by a
90 90 rule or maybe it's the you know
the just-in-case rule but souvenirs
specifically I will avoid getting
anything that I know I'm going to it's
gonna be really really hard for me to
break free from but what I'll say a man
is like going around the world and
travelling and putting this in a
practice it has built that muscle to the
point now where I don't even crave
souvenirs if anything I'll go back I got
pictures you know uploaded to my
computer like I'll go back on with the
pictures and remember the good times and
you know try to try to oh trigger some
of those memories from those amazing
trips you don't need the things to do
that exactly so so yes me me you you've
got to get some momentum built yes start
with the small stuff start with the
things that you can let go of easily but
you know the other way I look at this
too man is like I think about drug
addiction and how does one stop being
addicted to drugs and and this is
probably a little bit of an extreme
example for most when it comes to our
things but if you think about the
process of getting rid of that addiction
you first must recognize that you have a
problem then you must start to take
steps to rectify that problem it might
be getting some support from someone
else maybe going and you know seeing a
counselor or something it might be
having an accountability buddy who is is
there a sponsor that you can call when
you're really having a hard time but
ultimately when you think about drug
addiction you have to find a way you
have to find a way to break the cycle
you have to find a way to change your
state you have to find a way to start
moving forward in a different way yeah
so if you want to break free I think
that's a great analogy I think of a ship
that is out at sea and and if you want
to go somewhere you have to pull your
anchors up but the first thing to do is
stop putting more anchors down right and
that's what we're doing in our everyday
culture and our credit cards and and our
spending habits have enabled us to
actually continue to bring on
more anchors and the first thing you
have to do is stop playing the anchors
out there right so how do you yeah so
how do you stop being attached to stuff
well first stop buying so much stuff
stop bringing the stuff into your life
yeah I totally agree yeah all right so I
think I think that is where you start
and then weaken your attachment don't
start with the most difficult things
eventually you will get there but let's
start with those weak attachments break
that cycle build that letting go muscle
and then you'll be able to move forward
to the things that are more difficult it
really comes down to habits man and make
it this makes me think of to when you
gave up someone had you know I figured
what article it was or what radio
interview one of the first times I was I
was interviewed by a guy named Craig
what are your what are your most prized
possessions when you're the favorite
things that you own he had a blog called
simple black coffee I think is what it
was called or and yeah he asked that
question like what are the your three mo
what are your three favorite item it's
kind of like a gotcha question I know
you're a minimalist but what items do
you have that you were just not willing
to part with what do you love yeah I
think that's the implicit message yeah
it is like one of the things are
difficult for you to get rid of right
and so I got to thinking about that
night I had a favorite shirt at the time
was from j.crew was like this button-up
striped shirt and then I had this pair
of jeans and I had this pair of Allen
Edmonds shoes and I might here my three
favorite pieces of clothes I really
enjoy them I feel comfortable in them
but then I got to thinking like wait a
minute why are these my favorites
they're just clothes right and I said
you know what hey Craig here here are
the here are my three favorite pieces of
clothes and I send in pictures but what
I'd like to do here is I'd like to just
give them away to someone who can give
value from them and what I realized in
that process is they're just things
they're replaceable things yeah and
other things actually stepped up and and
here's the thing that sure I guarantee
if I would have held on to I still owned
us today it would no longer be my
favorite shirt now and by letting it go
I realized I could also let go of that
attachment it helped me build that
letting go muscle yeah what a great what
a great idea for someone out there who
has a hard time
letting go of stuff pick something that
you're not gonna be devastated if you
let go of like I think about something
that's a little difficult right exactly
I was thinking I'm thinking about when I
was going through the packing party
stuff and I had that shoebox of the
letters to my that my mom wrote wrote me
in high school there was you know
pictures of me and my prom date so forth
and so on
and I picked one thing out of that box I
picked a letter for my mom and he sold
it on eBay that's right I scanned it I
put it in the trash I did not feel that
much pain although there was this
feeling that I was going to have so much
pain letting that letter go well two
things we make things way harder than
what they actually are right so that's
first and foremost the other thing too
is dude I scan that letter I have not
read it since I scanned it so the the
physical possessions that I was holding
on to that I thought had so much
sentimental value well they just didn't
really mean as much as I had initially
thought and just getting a little bit of
courage to let go of that one letter
getting some courage to let go of that
pair of jeans that pair of shoes dude
those shoes told I got David a job
member that yeah so we have a friend he
lives in Chicago now but he lived in San
Diego at the time and so I put up the
the post about Hayes if anyone wants
these just send me an email and why why
they would add value to your life Alda
send it to you right yeah in a pair of
shoes
well he emailed me and he was ahem about
to go on this job interview I can really
use a nice pair of shoes it helped me
feel confident for this job interviewing
there were nice pair shoes Alamance
makes really nice shoes they're good
dress shoes he's I mean I got the job
and I got the job after wearing these
shoes interview now I don't think a pair
of shoes will get you the the job but I
think for him it was like it was added
this piece of confidence sharing him and
you realize something for for free can
your confidence is free in a way yeah
and I wasn't gonna I was gonna get
nearly as much value as he got from from
those pair of shoes so me letting go
actually helped other people in the
process
yeah dude so I guess the moral of the
story is is you know not only do we make
things a little bit harder in our minds
before we we take action on
the other thing too is sometimes we take
the action and not only is it not as
difficult as we anticipate it but there
are some amazing benefits that happened
from letting go so yeah me me take a
little courage find something that you
can let go of and get some momentum
built you ready for a Magdalena's
question I am alright how have you kept
your relationships and your minimalist
life among people who only care and talk
about things and money so Josh how do
you uh well yeah mostly everyone I hang
out they just talk about things and
money well you know you know it's funny
reading this question dude it makes me
kind of repository lationship s-- and
your minimalist of life among the shitty
relationships you had I mean so a long
time ago I I wrote an essay called
letting go of shitty relationships and
you can find on our website I'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
man I'll tell you it's one of the most
difficult things I had to let go of so
you don't start with letting go of the
shitty relationships or the toxic people
but one thing you realize you have if
you have these victimizers in your life
they're going to continue to victimize
you now that's an extreme example and I
don't want you to be the victim of their
consumerism in a way right we all need
some stuff and I will talk about things
from time to time or things that I get
value or we'll talk about money from
time to time absolutely things and money
are two things that make the world go
round right right but I would much
rather talk about those things with
respect to our values and our desires
our needs our once as opposed to well
just a sort of vapid consumerism that is
propagated by advertisements and the
everyday media and so when I when I
think about Magdalena's question here
the the thing that I think about is man
you need some new friends and that's
okay yeah I need some new friends and it
doesn't mean that your current friends
are evil
no but they just don't align with your
values and beliefs and and that's okay
and you know what it may be it may mean
that you didn't know what those values
were for a really long time and now all
of a sudden you're uncovering those
values and you're realizing that many of
the relationships that you have right
now are birthed out of proximity and
convenience meaning you work in the
cubicle next to them there happen to be
that grew up in the same neighborhood as
you they attend the same networking
events or you you hang out at the same
bars or nightclubs they're the same
school yes yeah and so you have these
relationships that are there because of
proximity but they're not birthed from
the same sets of values now I think
about my relationships and it's take a
long time you and I discovered
minimalism almost a decade ago now we
were just in Nashville and I have a
bunch of friends in Nashville so they're
certainly not relationships because of
proximity right we spent some time with
our friend Griffin house we went over to
hit the Griffin house house hold hey
don't worry don't worry Shauna clean
that up and really awesome yeah so so we
are Griffin houses house with him and he
has the two best kids I've ever met
the afterword I said hey I was talking
to Beck's on my hey Beck's how can we
get our daughter love me as much as
Griffins kids love me and I had such a
blast with his two kids yeah and and
just with the the relationship that
we've developed with Griffin over the
years he's he's one of our favorite
musicians ever and and not only does he
have great music so we share similar
values with respect to creativity but we
also we grew up in similar situations we
actually all grew up in Ohio even though
none of us live there any now I grew up
in Dayton yeah and so he he has similar
values to us and so I don't see him all
the time we've maybe seen him twice in
the last year he was in LA doing a tour
stop we were in Nashville doing a tour
stop and when we do make time when we do
we were in the same city we make time
for each other
so in order for someone to be my friend
doesn't mean I need to see them every
single day the next day in fact we went
to go see Austin Hartley Leonard here's
another talented musician he has a band
called broken anchor you can check out
their music wherever you get music love
his music in fact his song he has a song
called Ohio even though he's not from
Ohio so good one of my top five favorite
songs of all time and and I love him and
I love his wife Amy I haven't seen them
in four years they used to live in Los
Angeles before we lived in Los Angeles
and now that we live in Los Angeles they
live in Nashville and it's been 40 I
have talked to him on the phone a couple
times we tax occasionally but we're able
to pick up when we're in the same city
we have the most meaningful times
together and I do this over and over and
over our good friend Adam who we went to
high school with I worked with the same
restaurant in high school we get to see
him once a year for lucky mmm but I have
some of the most meaningful
conversations with him on the phone or
in person when we do have the chance and
it's because I'm not starved for
spending every moment with them it'd be
nice if they live in the same city as me
but what's more important is their their
value structure and who they are as a
person and having those meaningful
relationships the quality is so much
more important than the quantity
absolutely man you know here's my guess
my short answer to Magdalena's question
so she asks again how have you kept your
relationships in your minimalist life
among people who only care and talk
about things and money
we didn't yeah we didn't keep those
people around and it's not and again
this isn't a judgment against those
folks it is if anything it's a judgment
against myself right and in saying like
well this is you know what this is where
my values and beliefs lie and I'm not
willing to compromise those and I don't
want to hang out with anyone who isn't
supporting those values and beliefs do
you like birthday cake Ryan that kind of
thing what a dumb question of course you
do do you like tuna steak you could take
a birthday out of there
just any cake in general do you like
tuna um yeah it's pretty good yeah but
when you mix the two together it tastes
awful tuna cake patent pending yeah try
it out you let me know how it works and
that's that's really where it Magdelena
know like minimalist bakers listening to
this right now and she's like I'm gonna
do tuna cake look on Josh's face here's
the thing that's where Magdalena is
absolutely she is mixing tuna with cake
and you're not saying that one is great
and one is awful you're saying these
there are two things that don't work
together anymore
in my life my values no longer work with
the values of the current people I
surround myself with so what is the
answer you have to change the people
around you because you can't change the
people around you Samir has a question
for us our next question is from Samir
how do you reduce your entertainment
expenses and still keep your kids happy
you know here's the thing like you're
not I so I have a five-year-old and
keeping her entertained is generally not
that expensive dude I have seen I have
been around you Bex and Ella I can't
even count how many times
uh-huh and never has money but involved
in making Ella happy why I take that
back we went to Disneyland that cost
some money but but by and large like
when we're at your house hanging out or
wherever we're going for a walk or we
were you know watching the gay pride
parade I mean they're very very few
times where I've been hanging out where
Mariah and I've been hanging out with
the three of you and we've had to spend
money to keep the kid happy minimalism
is not about deprivation and we do want
to make sure our kids are happy but we
also want to make sure that we take care
of their their well-being their their
well fed yes we want them to be
entertained but I also unless worried
about the perpetual entertainment
because Ryan if I just wanted to
entertain Ella all day I would just turn
YouTube on and she would watch Peppa Pig
for 14 hours a day and it'd be a
miserable existence long-term she'd be
pacified in the moment so how do I work
on entertaining her I focus less on
entertaining her and I I focused more
nourishing her and I don't just mean
like through food although that is
certainly important minor --is-- her
mine how do I get her engaged how do I
keep her learning but then when I think
about money and entertainment one of her
favorite toys right now is I bought a
lamp recently it's like a desk lamp
because I get up early and I need a lamp
on my desk because it's just super dark
there when I'm writing and it came in
this oversized box you know when you get
something and you're like why is the box
that like yeah like you order like you
order a bottle ibuprofen from Amazon
yeah right with a bunch of packing
material in it right yeah this one had
this massive box for a lamp that is
about as big as if you're watching this
on YouTube it's about as big as this mic
stand so it's a decent sized lamp but
the box is almost as big as me mm and it
is a fort a castle spaceship it is
everything that she wants with that but
that said I also buy her toys right I
don't want to deprive her so she has a
nice bin of toys that she likes to play
with that are interactive to help
nourish her mind so she's not passively
just entertaining herself she's actively
entertaining herself so maybe the better
question is how can we actively
entertain our kids as opposed to
pacifying them absolutely all right our
next question is from ray-ray says I
love the idea of living in a minimalist
home but it doesn't feel cozy I think
some rugs plants art and decorations
greatly improve the fields the fields
and quality of a room but they aren't
always necessary what are your thoughts
about those unnecessary things dude by
default they are necessary according to
Ray yeah man I think it depends what you
mean by necessary and unnecessary so I
look at all of my possessions and they
fit in one of three categories they are
either essential non-essential so maybe
that's what he means by unnecessary
yes and
junk now well maybe he means junk when
he says unnecessary so we need to get
clear on it using the same language I
think it's important so we when you're
looking at the people in your household
when you look at the stuff in your
household make sure you're using the
same language
now the essentials are what is truly
essential in my life I know I need a
roof over my head so I need I need a
place to live whether that's a apartment
a condo a house an air B&B I need some
sort of housing situation for me to live
and that's the essential now the non
essentials are things like my couch so
we did this thing called living room
conversations where we recorded like 30
different interviews or conversations in
my living room so you if you go to our
YouTube channel you can see my living
room there's a couch in there now I I
could I get by without a Calif Ryan sure
probably yeah I think I'd be okay
without a couch but it does add value to
my life so it's a non-essential item but
I truly get value from the third the
third category is junk and that's what
my life used to be filled with mostly
was junk 90% of my things were probably
junk but I pretended they were necessary
and and so if you mean by unnecessary if
you mean junk then I say you know you
probably don't need any junk but if you
come over to my house I don't think
you're gonna come over there and say
this is Stark or this isn't cozy or
maybe you will and that's okay the
question is what are the things that add
value to your life and if you can afford
those bring them into your home what is
appropriate for your home may not be
appropriate for mine and you have to
adjust accordingly yeah I mean Ray's
says here I think some rugs plant art
and decorations greatly improve the
fields and quality of a room I had all
those things yeah I mean that is then if
that if that for you Ray if that what is
what improves the the quality of the
room if those things truly add value to
your life
then bring him into your life man
minimalism is not about not being cozy
if you are a minimalist and you're like
oh man I love being a minimalist but I
hate not being cozy I mean I wish I was
allowed to have a rough snot yeah
there's not a set of rules there isn't
like anything that Josh and I are ever
gonna judge anyone for if anything we
relate but you know I would posit that
either sitting in a room and you're like
I'm a minimalist I love being a
minimalist
but it doesn't feel cozy you might be
doing it wrong yeah yeah and here's the
thing it may require you getting to that
point of a feeling as though it is
starkly you have to eliminate the excess
before you can figure out what will
truly add value to your life let's say
you've stripped down your house to
nothing
you're still complete you are a complete
human being in that empty living room
right now is your opportunity you've
temporarily deprived yourself now you
say okay like you and I were not on tour
for almost a year I was ten ten months
in 2014 I went to a hundred different
cities 119 different events I remember
getting back home and realizing two
things I had these sort of these
paradoxical viewpoints Ryan the first
thing I noticed was when we came back
home to Missoula Montana there were some
things I forgot that I owned yeah and
there were other things where I'm like
oh we've been on the road we've stayed
in a lot of people's homes they were
nice enough to let us sleep on their
couches and spare bedrooms and floors
and or we stayed in some Airbnb ease and
I realized like oh I haven't had a couch
in several years and I miss having a
couch so why not bring a couch back in
my life if I'm gonna get value from it
so if Ray wants rugs and and what else
did he want coffee tables or decorations
whatever get rid of all that stuff at
first maybe but then figure out what
will truly add value you come over to my
house now I have some decorations I have
little art pieces and I have a mirror on
the wall that is beautiful and I think
my furniture is art - like decks and I
worked really hard in fact you go back
and listen to our decorations podcast I
think was episode 119 where we talk
about the process of being very
deliberate of slowly populating our home
temporarily depriving ourselves was
slowly populating our home with the
things that will add value to both of
our lives - we instead of just me yeah I
mean Mariah and I we lived in our place
for nine months before we ended up
getting like a kitchen table because for
the longest time we really I would just
live with that I live without it and
then after nine months were like you
know what this is really inconvenient
yeah to not have a place to sit down and
eat yeah so we finally got one so so
yes ray if you are in a situation right
now where you you are not cozy you have
put yourself into this discomfort zone
maybe that is helping ray in some way
being in this discomfort zone I know
that's you know you and I talk a lot
about how that is from you know there's
a place from which you grow the most is
that discomfort zone yeah so what have
you learned ray what have you learned
during this discomfort yeah and now what
are you gonna do in your life to make
yourself feel cozy to make yourself feel
more comfortable yeah it's yeah it's
okay to be temporarily discounted to
have some temporary discomfort but man
don't don't look at the minimal as a
minimalist life is just constantly
making yourself uncomfortable that's not
that is that is that is not what Josh
and I advocate for and by the way my
cozy might be cluttered for you and your
cozy might be cluttered for me and
that's because what is appropriate for
me may be inappropriate for you yeah
dude I had a had a ex-girlfriend whose
mom had it was like over a hundred
Santa's that she would put out during
Christmas living her dead Sam no comment
but uh you know sit around I was
counting them and I was just and I
wasn't counting him for any other reason
than her and I were joking around about
how many Santa's do you think her in the
house it wasn't a judgment thing it was
more of a bet like I bet sure there's a
150 180
anyway I forget what the number was but
I remember as we're talking about it and
thinking about how she her mom I would
still look at her like she's a
minimalist in the sense that those
Santa's like really during the holiday
times makes her happy and makes her feel
cozy yeah I know that her grandkids
really love to you know playing around
with them a make them fight or you know
whatever man
III know that those were put out it's
not like she just took out a hundred and
fifty Santa's and then like threw him in
the middle of the room and then walked
out I mean every single one was like
deliberately placed was it too many
Santa's for me yeah dude one Santa's too
many for me it was inappropriate for you
inappropriate for me but totally
appropriate for her absolutely our next
question the next question is from Dan
how can simple living be achieved as a
free
an entrepreneur who's constantly under
the pressure of hustling as much as
possible to build a business and succeed
this brings up conflicting priority asks
question stresses me out it does because
I think well I think we get confused
here
well first off are you a freelancer or
are you an entrepreneur I'm circling
those two words they mean two different
things right you're freelancer if you
are and Seth Godin has written a whole
lot about this you're freelancer if you
take on client work for other people you
are an entrepreneur if you're building a
business now maybe you're doing both but
maybe you're just one and you don't need
to stop worrying about the other one
maybe you really enjoy freelance work I
mean design logos for other people and
that's what you want to do you're a
freelancer now maybe you want to build a
logo Empire and thus you have to hire
other designers then you're maybe an
entrepreneur and you're starting your
own business to do that now what Dan is
doing here is he's wearing a couple
different hats and I agree with you Ron
that would stress me out so he he asked
at the very end well he actually said
this brings up a lot of conflicting
priorities hmm well the best way to
limit the conflicting priorities is to
limit your priorities if you have a
hundred priorities then all that tells
me is you really have no priority as we
mentioned earlier in the episode the
book by Greg McEwan essentialism talks
about how we had priority as a word it
means the first thing what is your first
thing then because right now if you're
just hustling maybe you're confusing
busy work with productivity and if
you're confusing that I'm just gonna
hustle hustle hustle I'm working 80
hours a week okay but maybe maybe you
can get more done in 20 hours a week
yeah Tim Ferriss wrote the the 4-hour
workweek for a reason he didn't mean you
should only work four hours a week what
he meant was I'm going to delegate all
of this excess stuff the sort of
administrative thing so I can do the
unnecessary things the administrative
things roughly four hours a week so I
can
focus on the creativity the freelancing
or the Entrepreneurship the things that
I want to focus on and then of course I
allocate a small portion of time to
focus on the things like okay I know I
have to do a little bit of this admin
junk that I don't want to have to deal
with but everyone has to do is so I'm
going to prioritize that for now so
maybe what the thing I would ask Dan is
what is the one thing because you can do
all hundred things but you can only you
eat an elephant one bite at a time I'm
never eating an elephant Dan dude you
need to plan Dan the man with the plan
that's that's what you need you need a
way out of this and what I mean by that
is if you're an entrepreneur or if
you're a freelancer you have to set a
path for yourself and what I mean by
that like I'm just thinking if I was a
freelancer I guess we're entrepreneurs
technically aren't we yes so I am an
entrepreneur but about if I wanted to
start freelancing I would I would first
set up what does that freelancing life
look like how many clients do I need how
many or how many jobs do I need like
that the questions like that or what are
what is going to I know that didn't come
out right it's the questions like that
or is what is going to help me frame
that plan yeah it sounds like you're
saying what is my outcome right and by
identifying what that outcome is because
what he's gonna get a thousand new
clients is that kind of maybe he needs a
thousand new clients but maybe he just
needs twelve really good clients right I
think of Kevin Kelley Kevin Kelley wrote
wrote the blog post we'll put a link to
it in the show notes but uh thousand
true fans now that numbers an arbitrary
number but what he talks about in there
is you don't need to keep building and
building and building I need more and
more and more clients you need the right
number of clients that are appropriate
for you and so maybe if you're if you're
a freelancer and you just need 12 really
good clients then you can focus on
creating the best thing for those 12
clients as opposed to like hustle hustle
hustle I need more more more more more
clients do this that's the most
stressful thing about this question
hustling as much as possible because the
thing is is like dude we like you and I
could
some more mm-hmm I mean if the end goal
was to make as much money as possible I
mean I guess we could hustle more yeah
but that's not our goal it's gonna
reduce the quality of what we're what
we're trying to put out absolutely so so
Dan like what is what is that one goal
you have to get toward like why are you
hustling as much as well I want to build
up my business I want to be an
entrepreneur I wanna I wanna but great
great but what does that business look
like and what are you working towards I
know it's so easy to get caught up in
the let's just say yes and let's let's
keep ourselves hustling and busy so that
way we're at least doing you know
something with our time and maybe it'll
get us somewhere and and that'll get me
in that'll pay rent this month like if
that is the situation that you're in
right now Dan to get out of that again
like you've got to come up with you got
to come up with a better plan
what are you working towards but dude
I'm telling you like I was there just
hustling as much as possible yeah I mean
that was me in the corporate days and
it's because I didn't know what the hell
it was working towards all I knew was
that if I hustled a lot I'd make a lot
of money and then I and then I would be
happy because I was making a lot of
money and Dan's probably thinking well
you know as soon as I get this business
going I'm gonna be happy but dude if
you're hustling your ass off right now
like you might be setting the wrong
expectations for clients so and you
might be producing work that is subpar
and then they're not gonna send you the
referrals that you want they're not
gonna feel good maybe they're not gonna
come back to you as a client because
maybe you're not hustling maybe the
better word is you're just busy and if
you're busy that tells me that your life
is out of control Henry David Thoreau
who said it's not enough to be busy the
question is what are you busy about so
Dan what are you busy about what are you
hustling for what is your outcome here
and if you don't know that then yeah you
probably gonna keep hustling endlessly
you're gonna keep being busy without
understanding why you're busy if you if
we are just in reaction hustle mode
there's never gonna be a sign or an
indicator externally that says okay
you've hustled enough yeah you're not
you're not gonna get that that letter in
the mail says congratulations you hustle
you're way to the top you've reached
your 1 million puzzle right and you know
that's good and so I think instead we
need to look for instead of hustling
what is meaningful what is what is doing
something meaningful and then last thing
I'm gonna say to Dan here is help other
people solve their problems that's yeah
they need to be in an entrepreneur if
you if you help other people solve their
problems you all have to hustle as much
and and you're gonna feel like you're
doing something meaningful in this world
we'll do what we've learned is like if
you're adding value to people's lives if
you're if you are making an impact when
I say adding value whether we are
helping someone with their perspective
or whether we're helping someone head-on
with getting rid of an item or maybe
we're helping them uncover them whatever
it may be because you and I have done
such such an intentional job of trying
to help as many people as we can with
our story when their philosophy whatever
it may be because we've been able to add
value people want to help us yeah people
do I remember when I when we first start
I started the mentoring the mentor the
mentoring program on our site I had
people who signed up for a year of
mentoring and then they sent me an email
and they were like I didn't know how
else to support you so I just bought a
year of mentoring but I really don't
want any mentoring just wanna give you
500 bucks and that was great but but
that but that is you know to your point
Josh being an entrepreneur means that
you're solving people's problems and if
you can figure out a way to solve
people's problems even if you're doing
it for free people will go out of their
way to support you monetarily and I
think one thing that you and I have
modeled here and it's the opposite of
hustling is we focus on one major
project a year and everything else that
we do has to support that major project
so whether it's a documentary or a book
or a tour or whatever it might be
everything that we dislike we're just
working on one thing doing one blog post
this year know know what's the what is
the outcome right and then everything
else I do serves that up serves that and
if it doesn't what do I do I say no I
say no to it and we've had to say no to
some really phenomenal opportunities but
that is freed up time for us to say yes
to something that is truly
meaningful amen all right Erica wants to
know what are your thoughts on the tiny
house movement do you consider this part
of living a minimalist life of course
you can't be a minimalist unless you
live in a tiny house it has to be a
hundred and ninety square feet are
smaller that is what we've determined in
our minimalist rulebook available now
for 2995
Erica what what is what does the
question isn't about what Josh and I
think about the tiny house movement
Erica what do you think about the tiny
house movement yeah yeah does it does it
suit your life is that something that
would really add a lot of value to your
life is it something that would help out
the people you live with maybe you live
by yourself and maybe that's why it's
appealing to you but you know the tiny
house movement it is it's a tool that is
there it's it's I want to say readily
available I mean you can go out and find
a million different blueprints there are
you know a lot of different contracting
companies that are building tiny houses
now I mean it's a tool that we have
available to us to help us live a simple
life right to help us get a home you
know cuz that's part of the necessities
we have to have that yeah so you can get
a home maybe it's not you know a
thousand square foot maybe it is only
190 square foot but you don't have a
payment on that home and you are able to
stay warm you've got an indoor bathroom
so there are these things that we
absolutely need in a tiny house and it
helps us to live I can't help us a
little more simple life but man like I
Mariah and I I mean we're I'm six foot
she's 510 dude we were kind of tall
lengthy people I mean living in a tiny
house sounds it doesn't sound the most
appealing to Mariah and I right now but
that doesn't mean that it's not right
for you Erika I'm not a fan of the tiny
house movement I am a fan of the
appropriately sized house movement and
for some people 190 square feet is
appropriate and then I'm a fan of that
for them and I'm a fan of allowing
people to pursue what their preferences
are I really think it's nice I like what
our friend Graham Hill is doing with the
tiny apartments and especially in cities
like New York City
where we he's in our documentary and
they have that 420 square foot apartment
to sleep seven and you could have dinner
for 10 in the house and and you can have
a movie theater screening of light with
8 people and all in this 400 square foot
place because it's modular and things
come out of the ceiling in the floor and
you got a stand-up desk and a cat you
have all of these things where they're
using that space to the best of their
ability I really like that because that
400 square feet feels way bigger because
they have some taller ceilings it feels
way bigger than 400 square feet yeah now
Bex and Ella and I live in a place that
it's probably 900 square feet I don't
know
I don't measure my square footage but
what I know is it's appropriately sized
for us there are two bedrooms there's a
living room / dining / kitchen area and
a couple bathrooms and that's really it
that's what is appropriate for us
however I that wasn't always appropriate
for me I used to live in a loft a loft
apartment because that is what worked
for me when I was single it was just me
by myself let's just have this this one
room that is appropriate for me so what
is appropriate today may change tomorrow
the living space that you need right now
might not be the living space that you
need tomorrow I think about the empty
nesters who keep their you know big five
bedroom houses and all four kids are out
of a house and all of a sudden they're
like well I guess we'll just hang around
here we've got way too much house and so
what do they try to do they try to cram
a life into that house because it's all
that they know as opposed to finding a
new house that fits whatever their new
lifestyle is and so regardless of the
the square footage of your house I would
encourage people to not feel compelled
to cram someone else's version of an
ideal life into that square footage find
the square footage that's right for you
but always be willing to adjust
accordingly yeah man you know even if
you and I were big fans of tiny houses
and let's say we were like living the
tiny-house dream I mean we would not
impose that preference on other people
exactly yeah and if you have a
three thousand square actually I think
the average house being built last year
was forty three hundred square feet or
something you know what there are plenty
of people who get immense value from
something like that and I'm not one to
judge however if you look at the heatmap
study it's in our documentary on a
monthly basis we tend to use about 40%
of our of our households on average so
most people aren't going to get
basically they're gonna use half the
space that they live in right now and so
the way we can fix that is by having a
more appropriately sized place to live
yeah all right our next question is from
you daya you daya asks you have any
ideas for making simple living fun for
my family and kids no it's boring yeah
you know fun and stupid get your fun out
of this room right now get the fun out
of here no fun that's what I tell
actually you were doing that the other
day we were having dinner with the the
six of us
Mattia Vela was over there filming some
stuff for our new documentary and you
kept telling Ella she wasn't allowed to
have fun anymore and like she was
antagonizing you she like go do
something have fun hey Ryan look I'm
having fun right and and so man I mean I
don't really understand the the question
ideas for - making simple living fun for
family and kids the whole reason that
I've embraced living a minimalist life
or simple living is so I get this stuff
out of the way that wasn't adding value
to my life so I could enjoy life more
now that said I don't I don't look I
don't constantly look for fun I'm not
the type of person who's going out and
I'm gonna see what I can do for fun
today right I do enjoy my life now Ryan
you do a whole lot of activities that I
mean you were surfing yesterday you do a
bunch of stuff for fun now that maybe
you couldn't do when you were stuck
working 80 hours trying to amass the the
trophies to show everyone else you were
successful yeah yeah no III think I
think you died a man if you're trying to
make this fun for your kids like kids it
doesn't take much for a kid to have fun
makes you think about that question
about the how do you you know
save money on entertainment tab it's
like kids do not need a bunch of things
they don't need you to spend a bunch of
money going to the ocean is free here
right in order in order for kids that
fun so like for me um dude I know kids
get really excited about helping other
kids yeah so if you are someone who has
children and you want to get them really
excited about simplifying or minimalism
I mean I wouldn't use either of those
words with especially if like a
five-year-old like Ella right but what
you can do is you can start instilling
habits in them like hey you've got a lot
of toys this toy box is overflowing and
there are some toys in here that you
don't play with there are some kids out
there in the world who have no toys how
would you like to help those kids out
like that that's how you're really going
to help kids get into that that that
spirit of of minimizing I guess and
giving the spirit of giving yeah and and
the thing that I've realized with Ella
when when she gives she also gets from
that and said in a way it's a sort of
instant gratification not just
gratifying the needs of others but
gratifying her own desire we all have a
desire to give and it's especially
pronounced in in kids they they want to
share sometimes I want to overshare like
with the food on her place she's
constantly trying to feed me food that
she doesn't like on her plate but part
of that is in the spirit of giving and
so yeah I don't use the words I mean the
only time that Ella uses the word
minimalism or minimalist is when she
does the intro to our YouTube videos and
she actually you know she says Oh
minimus and and you know Dave did a
little graphic for that but otherwise we
gonna talk about minimalism we show it
through the actions as opposed to these
sort of words these definitions yes we
all need to have a common language but
it's much more important to have common
actions if we want to get somewhere yeah
and I could see we're like gamifying you
know some things maybe that would create
a spark a little bit more interest like
when I think about the 30 day minimalism
game I mean you know like you were
talking about earlier man decluttering
is kind of boring but if you kind of put
this challenge behind it and you have
someone else that you're approaching
this
challenged with it does gamify it and it
doesn't make it a little bit more fun
but you know trying to gamify everything
that that might be setting up the wrong
expectation not just for your kids but
your for your family members too because
you know minimalism or simplicity it
ain't easy right it's just simple right
and and you know trying to make
simplicity look super easy or super fun
well that's just that's just not the
right attitude towards simplifying I
think yeah there are certain things you
can do that will help you get additional
traction but for me if you want to have
more fun then I think about when our
kids having the most fun usually at a
playground right mmm think about a bunch
of kids going to a playground I think
Ellis is the playground now why do they
have fun there it's because they have
what they need to have fun now what if I
put a bunch of obstacles on the
playground what's your spikes sticking
up everywhere or just a bunch of clutter
or I tip over the the the swing set or
whatever if there are things in the way
of the fun it's going to be less fun so
minimalism has been a way for me to get
rid of that excess stuff to make room
for the fun to make room for enjoying
life all right man you ready for
denzel's question let's get I'm pretty
sure it's Denzel Washington you wrote
this in alright then son wants to know
is it possible to be a minimalist as a
teenager you know what our audience
before our documentary came out skewed
to be more our age you know you and I
are 37 well you're almost 37 and how
dare you and you know a lot of people in
our audience we're 35 to 55 years old
and since our documentary came out and
especially as we doing more stuff on
YouTube I've noticed a lot of people
showing up to our vents who are in
college or are in high school
yeah and we're seeing more and more
people who are young who are being
influenced because they're realizing the
perils of their parents ways of living
and I wish I would have known about
minimalism in high school man or over a
teenager yeah I wish I wish I would have
well knowing about it and connecting
the way I do our two separate things
right but I wish I knew about it and
connected with it the way I do now
because in high school and there are so
many pressures whether it's wearing the
right you know pair of shoes or pair of
jeans I mean my dad would never let me
wear a pair of janko jeans but I'm one
of them so bad in high school well I
wouldn't let you wear them because they
were worldly
and that's aren't Levi's worldly - yeah
dude that's that's a whole other
conversation and worldly basically means
that you're not a Jehovah's Witness um
and and yes those were too worldly it
looked worldly but anyway
the pressures though of having you know
not just the right the right clothing
but listening to the you know I was made
sure that I was a fan of the right you
know of the right band or group or
singer song whatever man like there are
all these pressures that we have in high
school these preferences really that are
forced on us other people's preference
yeah so they're forced on us through uh
you know the kids that that they were
forced on me through the kids I went to
school with they were also forced on me
through advertisements video yeah
through the media so having all of this
pressure of other people's preferences
minimalism would have been great to help
me filter through all those preferences
that really figure out what it was that
would have added value to my life as a
teenager cuz do my what I'm so glad I'm
not in high school anymore dude I like
some people look back to like man I
really miss those high school I do not
miss high school
I do not miss being confused I do not
miss not being able to decide on my own
preferences but I do like to think that
if I again would have connected with
minimalism like I do now that maybe it
would have been a little bit better for
me a little bit less hectic I agree I
think that when I think about you know
the the high school years and and my
preferences and they were often dictated
by other people's expectations but guess
what that also happened in my 20s and it
would have continued to happen in my 30s
in my 40s and my fifties other people's
expectations what I've learned from a
lot of our events that we're going out
and when these teenagers are showing up
it used to be that like parents were
dragging their teenagers to our events
and now we have
dragging their parents to the event in
fact our event in Louisville recently we
were we were doing the the VIP event
beforehand where we give have like a
little 45 minute discussion with a small
group of 20 to 50 people who who have
the best seats in the house basically
and we're just having a conversation I'm
given this really good talk about your
minimalism I feel really good about I
also I turn around and my former boss is
there Jeff Moore he hired me when I was
18 years old he's the first person to
hire me in a telecom and man about
crafting my pants like I was like oh my
goodness
here's the guy who you know ruined my
life for 12 years he didn't actually
actually what Jeff did was he instilled
some serious extraversion skills in me
because I was such a shy extreme
introvert that without him taking me on
board and forcing me to talk to people
via sales and retail sales and
door-to-door sales and all this other
stuff I would not have been able to
communicate with people the way that I
do now because I was so introverted
there's no way I would have been able to
break the spell on my own I needed that
push at first and so the push for me was
like was the full immersion into that
and he helped me do that and afterward
we were talking and it was his 22 year
old daughter Emily who who dragged him
there from Cincinnati down to Louisville
to come to our event and and you know
she had found us when she was in college
and watched a documentary and read the
books and she was talking to him about
our books and our blog and our podcast
and he's like you really know these guys
like and he brought me some old pictures
of me when I was 18 I had my head shaved
and I was a mess I was wearing a suit I
looked like a like a preacher from did
you put any of those on Instagram no I
brought the pictures home though so I
probably should that'd be good nobody
before now give I give them the Jess for
back throwback Thursday Instagram
stories she'll she'll enjoy that but my
whole point is it we used to wood it
back in the day would have been someone
like Jeff bringing his daughter there
and saying see you can be a minimalist -
and now
I'm saying or people like Emily who were
showing their parents like hey I know
you've lived this one way and I'm not
telling you to change your life what I'm
telling you is we can always simplify
and for me that's the number one lesson
of minimalism no matter where you are
age wise you could be young or old no
matter where you are on the
socio-economic ladder rich or poor you
and I have been both and we've been in
between no matter where you are with
respect to your age your socioeconomic
status your social class no matter where
you are geographically no matter what
your ethnicity is we see people from all
walks of life that are at our events
minimalism really applies to one group
of people people who are dissatisfied
with whatever the status quo is and they
want to make a change they want to
simplify and so if you're a teenager and
you're unhappy with what the status quo
is then yes but also if you're a senior
citizen and you're unhappy with what the
status quo is then yes I think
minimalism can apply to you if you're
anyone in between and you're unhappy
with where the status quo is in your
life then yes then maybe simplifying a
little bit is right for you yeah man I
think also about if you're you know if
you're overwhelmed because that would
those things certainly would overwhelm
one and dude I think about one of the
most overwhelming times in my life it
was as a teenager man absolutely man
all right our next question is from Lisa
Lisa says do you look to other cultures
for inspiration on simple living and if
so which cultures do this is America we
America does not have a culture I mean
yeah we have to steal other people's
cultures what is it's weird we talk
about American culture but really it is
we often refer to America as a melting
pot but I think as more of a plate of
with all these different side dishes and
all of these side dishes are are
different cultures and I actually tend
not to look at cultures I tend to look
at individuals and and because that's a
lot more important to me because I don't
look at a Japanese culture or the
Swedish culture of you you can say that
a lot of minimalism has been inspired by
both cultures or maybe it's the simple
living
culture of the 60s or the than the
rebirth of that in the 1990s or maybe
you you can talk about other use in
Buddhist culture but to me those are
less appealing than looking at
individual examples of people who have
changed their lives and let me tell you
why I I see individuals like when we
first embraced minimalism I didn't say
well here is Kourtney Carver who lives
in the Salt Lake City culture no it was
Kourtney Carver who was a 40 year old
mother she had a teenage daughter it was
a specific example a specific recipe
that I looked at Colin right he was
24-year old traveler I didn't say well
here is the the Midwestern white guy
culture no cuz he doesn't represent most
white guys in the Midwest he's so
different from most white guys in the
Midwest and so I when I look at I think
I there's this huge failure of identity
politics of lumping people into these
different buckets but I think as
individuals we are all different I mean
I put up a picture of me and my brother
he came to our Louisville event and he
was first time he I asked him but is
have you been the Louisville recently
it's like they I haven't been to
Louisville since you and I went to a
master P concert when we were 14 you see
I remember being at that concert there
most of the 2000 people there and I was
the only white boy and the entire I was
front row Master P concept like that was
your entire like high school life dude
you were here are the only white kid in
a lot of situations but I didn't look at
it as like well I'm immersed in black
right here in fact I put a picture of me
and Jerome my brother on Instagram and I
said if you can't tell us apart I'm the
one on the left now we couldn't look
more different he probably weighs 100
pounds more than me and he still built
like a giant brick but also he's several
shades darker than I am but I don't look
to Jerome and say well talk to me about
black culture I said what kind of learn
from from you as an individual I said it
with you or I'm like Lou
what does Greco American culture I
looked at mr. Nicodemus here know I can
learn
from you as an individual I don't want
to learn from white women I don't want
to learn from black men I don't want to
learn from this culture or that culture
so much as I want to learn from an
individual who might be from that
culture because no matter what culture
we're looking at there are good people
there are bad people there are great
examples there are terrible examples of
how to live a meaningful life and I want
to look at the good examples from any
culture and see how I can improve my own
life so I can live my most meaningful
life yeah definitely man I mean I do
look at Japanese culture a little bit
I mean being over there in Tokyo last
year the kind of sort of believe it's
been over a year since Mariah and I were
over there but do the functionality like
that the architecture and like they're
forced into kind of being a you know
minimalist sore they're forced into
simple living in Tokyo especially I mean
it's like five New York cities it's
insane how big it is and there's so many
people they have to make the most out of
the space that they have and they have
done an amazing job so there are certain
things that like when I go to different
countries and I'm immersed in different
cultures that I certainly admire and
want to imitate like I think about when
Mariah and I finally build ace I don't
think well Bobo tiny-home will build
like us I call it a simple home mmm
because you know it'll be it'll be
bigger than 90 square feet but less than
9,000 square feet more towards the 90
than the 9,000 but my point is is that I
think about that day when we sit down to
like kind of you know go over the
blueprints or to map this out what that
house is gonna look like and yeah dude
like I'm totally gonna look at the way
things that I remember and experience
while I was in Japan dude when I think
about certain things that I own like a I
think yeah the Calphalon oh the the like
poor overed kit that i had recommended
across yea the coffee travel kit thing
that is german-engineered there are a
few other things that are German at
Makita the sunglasses those are
german-engineered so there are certain
things that
I have that I look and I'm like yeah
like this is German made I mean is it
part of Germans culture to be good
engineers I don't know man but my point
is is like yes there are certainly
things from other countries that I
admire and yeah want to want to mimic
the engineering stuff man like I just
love I do love very well engineered
things yeah but well designed and and we
all know is you don't have to be German
or Japanese to be part of good design
right and there are their ingredients we
can get from those cultures I think
about we lived in Montana for a while
five years I would often sauna with
several people from the local Indian
tribe the Blackfoot tribe and they just
go to the same sauna as me and I learned
quite a bit from those individuals now I
can't speak for the whole tribe I mean
nor what I ever tried to but I can't
speak when when I would speak to an
individual and they would impart a
particular lesson on me now part of that
might be a lesson from their culture and
part of it might just be a lesson from
that individual I try not to parse them
out as much as opposed to say wow Tom
taught me this as opposed to well the
Blackfoot Indians they are the ones who
imparted this wisdom on me I got that
from someone who was in that culture but
ultimately I got it from Tom yeah all
right our next question is from Claire
Claire asks how do you maintain simple
living without the fear of missing out
oh dude I just don't miss out on
anything anymore the fear of missing out
is such a every time I catch myself
doing that now like I just realize how
if I'm oh I'm doing this one thing I
could be doing this other thing there
are 99.9% of things that I could be
doing with my moment yes I'm missing out
on yeah and you know when it comes down
to for me is am I making the best use of
my time for what living a meaningful
life means for me
so am I am i recording a podcast right
now yes I am and do I fear that I'm
missing out you know time with Mariah or
maybe I could be surfing today in fact
they did have an opportunity to go
surfing today and I could
went surfing today if we didn't have
this podcast recording but am I gonna
sit here and get upset about it no
because right now we're recording a
podcast this serves my meaningful life
this is contributing towards me living a
meaningful life so as long as the the
things that I do in my life contribute
towards that I have I've kind of
accepted the things that that I'm
missing out on so I guess maybe another
way to like there's a litmus test that I
could you know probably use it's like
can I look in the mirror and be
satisfied with the way I have used my
time and if it isn't then I got to ask
myself okay why am I upset with the way
I use my time and then correct from
there yeah and I think that's what's
important about that is you're
constantly evaluating and not striving
for perfection what you're striving for
is how do i improve your striving for
improvement here's the truth
you are missing out you're missing out
on virtually everything before you were
born you missed out on everything that
happened the 13.7 billion years before
you were born you missed out on all of
it and after you die you're going to
miss out on everything that happens here
on earth after you are dead and
in-between between birth and death
you're still gonna miss out unfunctional
II a hundred percent of everything that
you're not doing right here right now so
how do I overcome that I ask myself one
question is this the best use of this
time I often ask that question with my
money is the best use of this money
because maybe I'm gonna buy something
that will add value to my life but is it
the best use of that money and if it's
not maybe I bought something and it
wasn't the best use of that money I
don't have to regret it forever I could
feel that twinge of pain without
suffering long-term and I can say you
know what that was a poor decision that
I made with that money let me learn from
that so I don't make a similar decision
in the future and so are you gonna miss
out you're damn right you are but that's
okay
make sure that what you're doing right
now
is the best use of that time and then
you won't be worried about missing out
on the other things that aren't as good
of a use of your time anyway
absolutely art Logan asks does living a
simple life lead to an uninteresting
life I mean I can I guess so can living
a maximalist life that can also lead to
an uninteresting life so can living a
medium life that could also lead to an
uninteresting life and somewhere between
medium and simple that could also lead
to an uninteresting life what is what is
what is uninteresting though because
what is interesting to me Ryan is
usually uninteresting you know with you
and I we have radically different
personalities right like the joke is is
like man I really love that movie Josh
but you know what don't watch it it's
way too much fun for you yeah yeah and
I'll be like hey man I just watched this
movie was so good but you will
definitely think it's boring right oh
it's too boring for you to watch yeah
and the truth is like different things
interest me because we have different
interests and that's okay I don't want
to project my interest onto you well you
know all Ryan you should be interested
in reading all of David Foster Wallace's
you imagine if every single one of eight
or seven billion people of us probably
approaching eight billion people of us
on the planet could you imagine if we
all had the same exact preferences do
you know it'd be miserable
like we'd go to a movie and like
wouldn't be able to get a ticket because
everyone would be at the same movie
right we wouldn't be able to go to a
restaurant because everyone would be
that same restaurant yeah it would be
sick it would it would actually remove
all the interest it wouldn't make life
if we were all interested in the same
thing it would remove the variety and
you know what makes life interesting
variety hmm a change of pace because we
don't want to do the same thing over and
over and over Groundhog Day is what I
think of that's not interesting that's
that's crazy-making yeah I mean I love
that movie but living their life yes
yeah and and so I think back though I
think back to my 20s it is such an
unremarkable life hmm I had climbed my
way to middle middle management I was a
director of operations for Bubba Bubba
Bubba Bubba look at the title on my
business card
look at my Lexus I'm driving from my box
house in my box to my box office so I
can eat my box lunch and I'll heat it up
in this microwave box who cares about
that it's not interesting in fact I
wrote fiction throughout most of my 20s
because I didn't have anything
interesting to write about my own life
my life was not interesting and when I
simplified there was something
interesting about that do you know why
because my life was finally different it
was no longer part of the status quo it
required some sacrifice sure but you
know what I made up for with that
sacrifice I lived a life that was far
more interesting to me than this
template I had been thus old that I
didn't find interesting at all man yeah
dude all right we got one more question
well one more question before the
lightning round yeah before the
lightning round we got one from Brittany
she wants to know how can I slow down
and enjoy life well everyone around me
is so busy I mean I think about
sometimes we have to this is a pithy
answer for you could probably put this
in the podcast Sean if you're listening
to this wherever you are actually
podcast Sean is on vacation right he's
over at Glacier and who said podcast
Sean could take a vacation I never
approved that you know what we're really
great for you podcast Sean thank you for
doing all that you do and yeah we're
glad that you are enjoying the time with
your family just don't ever let it
happen again I think about this though
Ryan and you could put this as a minimal
maxim maybe sometimes you have to slow
down to avoid going too far yeah when
when we're just speeding along not
paying attention the muscle memory is
sort of kicking in have you ever done
this where it like you've moved and then
you accidentally drive to the old house
that you live that oh yeah dude or maybe
you changed offices when you managed a
bunch of different retail stores and you
accidentally drives like the Centerville
store even though you're managing the
Middletown store or something and you
end up there or you're almost there
whatever and you're like what am i doing
yeah it's because I didn't slow down and
when you
so down you drive too far you go too far
and yeah I get it sometimes if you slow
down it can feel like the world is just
blurring all around you you look at
those those scenes that are sort of sped
up in movies you do the time laughs
someone's walking through I was on an
airplane recently and whatever Liam
Neeson movies know what someone he's on
the train taking on a train I think it's
called I'm pretty sure it's called taken
on a train the commuter which is it's
basically taken on a train because you
know the takers I know the same thing oh
my god all right Liam Neeson movie but
there's a scene where he's walking
through like Grand Central Station and
like he's walking it's like a time loss
of his day after day after day
everyone's just speeding pass out and
that's what life can feel like when you
slow down yes people are gonna pass you
by but they're not getting where you
want to go they are going somewhere else
someone else is busy is not going to get
you where you want to go man it's funny
because like me watching everyone well
not everyone but I mean when I see
someone busy uh-huh it doesn't make me
want to be busy it just makes me
appreciate having slowed down oh yeah we
talked about the hustling thing earlier
when asked the question about hustling
and you're like man this stresses me out
seeing everyone else busy all the time
go go go go hurry hurry get things done
I don't want to do that once you've
actually slowed down yeah also remember
this is a chapter in our book everything
that remains my favorite thing we've
ever written it's called strong moves
slow hmm so keep that in mind too yeah
the the weak often are just boom boom
boom and I was actually weak I was
allowing other people to dictate my
schedule to dictate my to-do list to
dictate my inbox to dictate my life mmm
and in doing so I was weak because I was
like if you inflate a balloon and just
let it go
the side of the room that's out of the
room here there there it's busy that
balloon is busy but it's not going
anywhere
intentionally mmm it's just going and
going and going and that's busyness to
me but when I slow down it strengthens
my movements because I'm going somewhere
deliberately yeah and like you said man
letting someone else dictate your
schedule especially a busy person
dictate your schedule God that is as
miserable I mean in the corporate world
we were constantly putting out fires and
what's nice now is well other people's
emergencies they're not necessarily mine
because most emergencies aren't and I
think that's important to realize most
things in the moment seem like a a house
fire right I've read this thing from
Seth Godin I think it came out this
morning right on have you read it but he
talked about how a volunteer firefighter
sees a fire much differently from a
person who's trapped in a burning
building
right the volunteer firefighter seeks
that out because they want to solve the
problem they're prepared for it mm-hmm
they've moved slow up into that point
they're ready for it the person in the
burning building is panicked and I spent
most of my twenties in a burning
building a metaphorical emergency always
all the time I would could barely come
up for air because I was just gasping
flailing help help help I need to move
on to the next emergency and so I think
Brittany the thing you can do is
practice saying no say no to something
today say no to something else tomorrow
say no more frequently to those things
that are emergencies because just
because it's someone else's emergency it
doesn't mean it has to be your emergency
just say no all right so we'd love to
hear what you have to say so if you have
a comment or a tip about simple living
including advice for any of the folks
who asked us a question today then leave
us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you
can also email a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm where our favorite comments and
tips
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this week's podcast episode for this
week's listener comments and tips Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it is time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
indeed we do we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists during
the lightning round this is Ryan and I
each do our best to answer every
question we're just a short shareable
lesson 140 character response we also
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our quotes in one place thanks to our
good friend Jessica Lynn Williams over
at minimal Maxim's calm her first
lightning round question is from Eve
what are some tips for living a simple
life while working going to school and
taking care of two happy kids well
here's here's my pit the answer and then
let's talk about Orion okay as the chaos
grows so does the need to simplify Yemen
here's the thing so it's it's harder to
- it's harder to simplify a more complex
life right if you're if you're a monk
simplifying is already there right
you've already simplified it's not a
complected life it is already simple but
the more complex your life the harder it
is to simplify but the more complex your
life the more necessary it is to
simplify because you're going to get far
more benefits from the simplifying I
learned this from our friend Joshua
Becker who has a book called clutter
free with kids he also has a great book
called the more of less we'll put a link
to both of those in the show notes he's
also in our documentary and when I
learned from him is I didn't have kids
at the time but he had two kids and and
he said yes of course it was harder from
my simple my family to simplify then it
would have been for just me to simplify
because it requires working together
getting us all on the same page and it's
so much harder as a family but it's so
much more important as
yeah alright my simple answer is this in
order to stay focused with the full
plate because Eve that's what you got
right now you have a very full plate in
order to stay focused with a full plate
one must learn the art of saying no like
you were saying earlier it is an art man
because it's not just saying no to
everything and there is no and the
reason it's not of science of saying no
it's like well here's the algorithm here
are the things you should say no - yeah
there's a delicate but I mean there are
some things that are obvious you say no
- and what hey Ryan you want some heroin
during this podcast sure wait a minute
wait is that with an ear not a knee but
you want some heroin and some II during
this vodka now do you like yours like
you were just saying man it is it is
important to say no especially when
everyone else is so busy and when you
have a full plate when you are working
when you're going to school when you're
taking care of kids like those have to
be your priorities and you've got to say
no to to most things that don't serve
those priorities so it's it's it is I
think human nature for a lot of people
to just want to say yes to everything we
just want to help we just want to say
yes we're gonna help you move yes we'll
come over help you paint yes you can
borrow my car but when we say yes to
everyone else but we're telling
ourselves no in order to do so man that
is uh well that's one way to make
yourself really really busy that's a
recipe for chaos yeah absolutely and
talk about not feeling fulfilment or
purpose because if you're empty you
don't really have enough to give when
you need to give when giving is the most
important if you don't take care of
yourself first by saying no to these
excess things you're never gonna be able
to say yes to what's truly important yes
indeed crystal how can you make
housecleaning
a simpler process just throw away
everything why do you even have stuff in
your house yeah I mean it's funny it
didn't used to take me like all day to
clean
my house right back in and my Lotus
eating 20s I had I just had a lot of
stuff and along with that stuff the cost
of that stuff is also having to store
the stuff and clean the stuff take care
of the stuff dust off the stuff polish
the stuff and well here's my pithy
answer the fewer things you own the
fewer things you have to clean that may
sound overly simplistic and it may sound
like so obvious but we don't realize
like when you own considerably less
stuff you actually have considerably
less to clean it's so so so much easier
for me to to clean my home now now here
is the other thing I was a well-planned
hoarder I had an organized stuff so we
often confuse organizing with
decluttering they are not the same thing
if you own 300 thousand items and
they're all organized really well you
still have to clean all those damn
things and so getting rid of them helps
you have fewer things to take care of
yeah man my answer is right along the
same lines as yours cleanings easier for
minimalists that's just the less you own
the less you have to clean I got maybe a
couple tips that might help you out
crystal um clean often if you are
cleaning once a month it actually will
take you longer than if maybe you were
cleaning like two or three times a month
like I know for me it's like if I let
the if Mariah and I let the the floor go
unvaccinated buckets water comes a whole
problem yeah because the whole process
rather than if like on a daily basis
like Mariah she'll do some spot
vacuuming on the floor and then she'll
clean and I think once once a week maybe
once every other week but my point is is
that because we stay on top of it you
pretty often that you know and instead
of it taking nine buckets of water to
clean the floor she can get it done in
two buckets of water my mom taught me
this and it's I think one of the reasons
I've been organized for a long time
but clean as you go right I mean that
was the thing for me like even when
you're like especially you're making
dinner at night like and and backs like
doesn't always she's not on the same
page as me with this so I'm the one
who's willing to step up and clean as we
go as opposed to having 70 dishes at the
end of the night not the way that we
don't own 70 they should be here on for
the same like I know you told me not to
hands and just let me clean this plate
off real quick and then this is one
thing and it's gone and you don't have
that pile at the end of the meal or at
the end of the day and it's much easier
to deal with yeah dude I mean when we
were living together I saw you doing
that where it's like yeah we we would
eat you'd have your dirty plate and then
like it wouldn't just sit in the sink
dude like you'd wash it and put it in
the rack always and before that dude
like I would just you know I just would
stack dishes in the sink and then
eventually have a huge stack of dishes
or you know I would go to grab addition
like realizing they're all dirty and
then that was my indicator like oh and
now I have to clean that I spent 30 45
minutes cleaning stack of dishes oh and
by the way since I've been sitting there
for you know a few days now it's even
harder to clean because things have
dried and crusted to the plates where
when you wash something right after
you're done it is so much easier than
then yeah dealing with that that huge
stack the other thing else
the other tip I'll give dude what you
also taught me I think we talked about
this in like episode 20 or so I mean it
was it was a long time ago squeegees
dude squeegee in the bathroom I had no
helpful oh my god so like I had a
houseguest
who when Mariah and I were gone in
Australia when we were on tour in
Australia we had a houseguest come and
take care of the house take care of the
cat and one of my requests was look I
know this is weird but please squeegee
the shower when you're done with it it
makes it so much easier on us it's a
clean the bathtub to clean the bathroom
when we've been squeegeeing because you
don't have to sit there and get the
magic eraser and scrub [ __ ] off like you
can literally just like take a rag and
it's clean it's it cleans up really
really nicely
so what they did is they they did it
squeegee tall the shower walls but they
not once squeegee the tub and dude we
got back after a month I'm not squeegee
in the tub and it was like so much
faster Obbo Krys man like getting that
getting that tub clean well here's the
other thing with that there's like a
psychological clutter that comes along
with that if you let the dishes pile up
for four days or you let the the soap
scum pile up for you know four weeks
there's something area like I got a hat
I know I'm gonna have to deal with that
and it's just sort of weighing there
occasionally in the back of your mind
and you can remove that psychological
clutter but just taking a moment and and
and cleaning whether you're squeegeeing
doing the dishes mopping the floor
whatever it is it's much easier to spend
the five minutes now than spending the
five hours a month from now and allowing
it to weigh on your mind that entire
time in between PS Ryan we have one more
question oh yeah how does simple living
help you live a life without any regrets
so right I wonder what I want to talk to
you about with this is my past regrets
my current regrets and also something my
future regrets but if you want our
answer to that question then you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively for our patreon
supporters so if you want to support our
show and help keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our
monthly ask the minimalist anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events and the entire back
catalogue of our past private episodes
and once you become a supporter you'll
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so it plays in your normal
podcast player I think that's one of the
biggest things you don't have to get on
some you don't have to log on to
Internet Explorer or Netscape or
whatever you're using these days do you
still use Internet Explorer I use
Netscape still I still use AOL man but
it shows up right however you listen to
this podcast it shows up right there in
your podcast player and as a patreon
supporter you also receive access to
our monthly livestream videos as well as
first access to tickets to all of our
live events before those tickets are
available to the general public so you
can get the best seats in the house you
can find all the details and all the
good stuff over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode the way
we've eliminated the majority of our
regrets and we've also avoided future
regrets is by living a life that is
congruent with the person that you want
to be and it doesn't mean you're not
gonna have any regrets it means that by
living a meaningful life by getting the
excess out of the way and focusing on
what's truly important you drastically
reduce the amount of regrets that you're
going to experience in the future and if
you do experience them I think they're
going to be so significantly smaller
because it's like oh yeah I really wish
that you know we would have done four
cities instead of three on the simply
southern tour whatever it might be where
you're like yeah but okay I can live
with that their regrets that are much
easier to live with and those type of
regrets aren't really regrets they're
just lessons that you apply to the
future anyway okay now it's time for our
added value portion of the show this is
where Ryan and I talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently I've been listening to this
album and we were just talking about
high school a moment ago and and the
pressure of being a high school kid and
I found myself listening to I mean music
is tends to be young people make the
good music these days they dictate the
sort of music culture of what's going on
in music right yeah and this is gal her
stage name is snail mail and she has a
new album out called lush and she was
born after we graduated high school Roy
was born in 99
so yes we were getting old but her music
is it's beautiful the writing is
beautiful it's sort of like
singer/songwriter or folk rock I don't
know how you would describe it I'm gonna
see her in concert relatively soon as
well but she's new album out called
blush and I strongly recommend it and
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
there's just something about its is
she's what 19 I guess it's like teenage
angst but in a way that is poetic and
beautiful and man I think you will enjoy
the album I'll put it on when I'm
cleaning the house as a matter of fact
and just put it on and and it's just
sounds really good good cleaning music
yeah it was funny we were sitting down
with Austin Hartley Leonard last week
when we were in Nashville and he's like
approaching 40 and he's every time I
want to like sit down and make music I'm
thinking like I should probably do
something that's going to help you know
that it's going to do something for my
family that is beneficial for my entire
family and so I can't imagine sitting
down and working on the next demo for my
next album or something and I think 19
year old just aren't worried about that
and that's why they I listened some of
austin hartley Leonard's music from when
he was you know 25 or whatever 29 and
it's some of the best music I've ever
heard but he wasn't worried about you
know maintaining you know the lifestyle
for his family and making sure they have
Pampers and stuff and I think that's why
19 year old to make some of the best
music out there dude 19 year olds were
born in 1999 yes you're so old dude
right you so Mariah and I were moving to
new place really psyched dude it's we
have it's it's a one-bedroom
one-bathroom about 900 square foot with
views for days like it's one thing about
living in LA man it is like it is not
the montana views that i was used to
waking up to all the time but yeah i
think actually the what we're getting
ready to move into is even it's even a
nicer view than what we had in montana
what was funny is we were talking about
what is appropriate
me and you like part of that has to do
with preferences like yeah that's not
even in my top ten things of looking for
an apartment is how good are the views
but for you it's like number one on your
list and so it's really important to
realize like don't don't try to adopt
someone else's preferences because
you're gonna end up in a space that is
not appropriate for you
yeah absolutely so during this move
we've had to get some cardboard boxes
and dude use cardboard boxes that use
cardboard boxes calm it's great man
they have recycled boxes or you know pre
used boxes it's very it's as you know I
feel like as environmentally friendly as
you can get with purchasing new boxes to
me yeah yeah and they're very gently
used it tend to be I've used them once
or twice before and and what's nice is
the when they send em to you they're
often from other stores and they just
use boxes once or sometimes a store you
know order 200 boxes they only ended up
using 150 so they have 50 new boxes
still sitting around that they otherwise
would have just thrown out and so many
cases you're getting brand-new boxes
yeah so it's worked out really well from
Ryan I um it's yeah I mean if you're
moving and you wanna you want to buy
some like pre used cardboard boxes it's
it's really really convenient I mean I
like was I had started like walking
around and asking like the gas station
across the street that the liquor store
down the street
that's about the only two places I felt
like they would have some boxes yeah and
then I realized like wait a minute for
like 25 bucks I can just go get some
boxes not to worry and not spend three
hours trying to track some boxes down
yeah I worked out really well
Podcast make sure to put that in the
show notes all right let's move on to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist as promised we have a lot
going on this month but we're not busy
we've been focused on some really
important things we just finished up the
simply southern tour dude I am like that
was one of my favorite tours man it was
it was just incredible not only because
we went to the South which I love going
to the South man that southern
hospitality yeah it's
funny man like it there truly is like a
different attitude in the south and it's
just a lot of awesome people but so not
only just because of the you know this
the the the the southern hospitality but
also being with Ramsay's team and and
having these experts onstage with us
talking about finances like yeah I wish
I was the finances guy I wish that like
people they could just say yeah
Nicodemus you got money that you need to
put somewhere go talk to that he knows
exactly the right investments he knows
exactly the stocks you should buy the
index funds you should I am NOT the
money guy I do I mean I got some good
advice but all the advice I have I have
stolen from Dave Ramsey and his team so
to have like those experts actually
there to speak to some you know not just
some like problems from a high level I
mean certainly there's some good
budgeting advice and in different advice
for going to college but the fact that
like we could answer people's specific
questions to their life so help helping
folks with their finances there are
specific problems with finances like one
of the one of the things I love about
the live podcasts is that we get to have
a conversation with a person that's
asking the question so all these
questions that we asked at the beginning
of this episode there are some follow-up
questions I would love to ask some of
these folks right we're when we're doing
a live podcast we could ask those
follow-up questions yeah we got to do
that specifically with with the finances
and I just can't wait for those episodes
to come out I know it's gonna add a ton
of value to a lot of people's lives so
we were in Louisville we were in
Birmingham we were in Nashville and
you're right yeah you and I can echo
many of you advice that we get about
money and you and I have made good
decisions with our money after many
years of making bad decisions or money
we've course-corrected but we're not the
we're not the voice on money right these
people Chris Hogan Anthony O'Neill
Rachael Cruz Dave Ramsey they're the
voice and smells okay just to be the
echo instead of us trying to rewrite all
of their advice and in ways that are
palatable know what we can do is say hey
here's the source here's the voice and
we'll just help echo that so the the
first episode the Birmingham one it was
episode 143 it came
last week and we're recording today it
actually came out if you haven't seen
the video for like if you just listen to
the audio the audio is great
check out the audio you've got to see
the video Jordan did a phenomenal job
with that and by the way the video just
gonna get better on future episodes I
think we will probably do we haven't
figured out exactly what the schedule is
but we'll put them out in future months
sometimes we save our live events for
just for the patreon feed and we could
talk about that in a second but another
thing that we did you can find this on
our website go to the minimalists comm
slash ramsey right before we left
Nashville we finish up the assembly
southern tour the folks from Dave
Ramsey's team said hey you want to come
on Dave Ramsey's radio show and I was
like holy moley
it was a real Dave come true saying that
because we start out this interview said
dude I was so alright yeah I'm sorry I
think I'm gonna take over the story so I
we got we got invited to go to Dave rant
on Dave Ramsey show I was so excited I
was so incredibly excited to be on his
show I was all nervous and the very
first thing that I say when we're on his
show he's like hey welcome to the show I
meant to say it's a dream come true Dave
but instead I was like it's a Dave come
true dream I did I did I did it and so
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
Dave Ramsey he's basically America's
voice on on finances 14 million
listeners in the United States and
third-largest radio show in the entire
country second-most radio stations over
over 650 stations I think we went to
their compound they have 700 and it's a
campus yeah 748 employees it's not an
actual compound but I you know it's it's
like it is a campus it's like a work
College yeah I mean it's a coffee shop
there they have a conference center
they're the ones who do the every dollar
app they have like 50 employees that
work on that every dollar app which is a
free app and they really are focused
hard on helping people with their money
problems and that's what they're there I
mean we are a country that is consumed
by debt
excessive spending and he wants to help
people rein that in in fact their
materials now are in 43 percent of high
schools I love it and so good he's
trying to shape future generations he
and his team of hundreds of people are
working really hard so if you want to
check out the interview we did with them
we really just had a conversation with
Dave you can check that out over at the
minimalists comm slash ramsey also check
out episode 143 check out the video
version of our what's that is that the
first video I'm sorry is that the yeah
is that the first video that we've
released for a live podcast for live
podcast yes awesome yeah it is
we did one event back in 2011 or 2012 I
think it was holiday happiness oh yeah
you could find that somewhere deep down
yeah that's right dude yeah one other
thing I want to say about Ramsey News
team it is it is so nice to go to a
corporation mmm and feel good about that
corporation like those guys are just
awesome morals like they their
intentions are good yes yes they profit
is like any other business you should
you know you should profit but they are
not profiting off of people's misery I
mean maybe they're profiting from them
eliminating their misery they're solving
people solve problems
absolutely but like just to be able to
see a corporation run that way it's just
yeah it just it feels really good to
have a corporation out there that isn't
evil and you and I got to sit down with
Dave individually that morning and one
of the things I told him is he wrote a
book called entre leadership which is
like entrepreneurship but leadership
because he doesn't believe in management
he believes in leadership and what I
told him is it's really refreshing to
see someone who doesn't just write about
you know these principles or whatever
but actually has it instilled in their
business practices so they run a
business that really helps just millions
of people and and he has helped so many
people not just get out of debt but
completely changed their family's
trajectory and they're they're the
future generations trajectory by getting
out of debt and planning for retirement
and contributing to the
world and a meaningful way so I'm really
grateful we had the opportunity to be
down there with them
check out the Birmingham event right now
it's episode 143 and I know we'll
release the other events somewhere in
the future either to the live or to our
podcast feet or on our patreon feed
speaking of patreon we just released the
Houston event so we did a Houston to
charity event last year for the
hurricane Harvey folks we donated 100%
of the profits from that by the way it's
simply sell dindt or 100 percent of the
profits are going to the gym city market
from that to help build a grocery store
in Dayton Ohio one of the largest food
deserts in the country is there on the
west side you can contribute to that by
the way if you were to go to the
minimalists comm slash dayton but on our
patreon feed right now we put out the
houston event and it was the i went back
and listened the beginning of it was a
day of that tragedy where mmm there was
a shooting there not far from Houston it
was in Texas that same day there's
another mass shooting and we talked
about dealing with that and the pain and
it was in the middle of it so I wouldn't
have answers or solutions but but try
and help people cope with the pain and
it was it was a difficult day I was a
somber day for me I remember that it was
a somber of them but I still felt really
good about the event and in helping
people with with that healing so you can
check that out over at the minimalists
comm slash support and you tube man
we've got a whole bunch of stuff going
on with youtube so the video version of
this podcast comes out a day early so it
comes out on Mondays we're starting new
versions of living room conversations I
think we're going to change the name of
living room conversations to really soon
we're gonna put out some we just did a
living room conversation with Rachael
Cruz we did one with Anthony O'Neill we
did one with Chris Hogan we'll put those
out we'll probably do about one of those
a week we're also gonna do some quickie
podcast episodes so we're gonna do some
excerpts from it I know some people were
like hey your podcast is too long I
don't want to listen for 90 minutes
okay well go to our youtube channel
there are going to be excerpts answering
individual questions we'll just tweeze
out some bits from our podcast and you
can find that over at youtube.com slash
the minimal it's also we're gonna do
monthly vlogs or gonna do tour recap
vlog and thanks to Jordan for getting
all of that together also some
minimalism tips somehow stores and other
you
tube shows we're gonna focus heavily on
creating meaningful video and film
creations for you because they seem to
resonate a lot with folks already talks
about my health diet and all the
carnivore stuff I'm doing I talked about
this briefly Ryan but our second
documentary we have one more scene to
film and we're filming in it this week
Yemen and so and then we're gonna work
on all the post-production stuff the
score and color grading and all that
stuff and I'm sure we'll go through
different edits and a whole editing
process but I'm excited to finally have
a first draft version of our next
documentary it's called the minimalists
less is now we hope to have it out by
the end of this year stay tuned for more
details on that if you're on our email
list on our website you'll be the first
to hear about details about that second
yeah about the second documentary but
also about any of the show notes so you
always hear us talk about the show notes
to every podcast if you want to get
those show notes in your inbox anytime
we come out with a new podcast just go
to the minimalists comm and enter your
email address there at the top and if
you want to leave a comment on this
episode you can leave it on youtube just
go ahead on over to youtube.com slash
the minimalist find this episode and
interact with folks who are leaving
comments about these episodes what else
you got for us Ryan
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi my name is
Kaylee I'm from st. Paul Minnesota I
just had a quick tip for Ryan actually
regarding the acquaintance podcast I
choose deleted Facebook greatest single
handily the greatest social media thing
I've ever done
you mentioned that that's how you
connected to some people as only on
Facebook the one thing you should know
is you can still use messenger
it's the app or the chat platform for
Facebook so even if you delete your
Facebook account people can still reach
you via messenger so it's just kind of
like its own text platform if you had
that to begin with like if you DM to
people on Facebook they can still do
that it would just come through the
messenger
hi minimalist this is best from Chicago
and I was calling in with a tip this
could be for clothing but also anything
else and I'll explain so when it comes
to clothing my rule is this if I would
rather go in to my hamper and rewear a
piece of item that's dirty
then get a like item out of the closet
so maybe it's a pair of jeans then it's
time for the jeans in the closet to go
so maybe that means just buying three
pairs and my favorite one then get rid
of the rest and that's good with me so
how that applies to other things so
maybe items like shampoo if you get done
with the bottle and you go out and buy
that same one again rather than using
all the other half used ones in your
closet
time to go and same with maybe a pot or
a pan if that one breaks and you're
going to go out and rebuy that same one
instead of using ones that you already
have that are the similar size then it's
time for those ones to go as well hi
this is Molly from Salt Lake City
I'm calling the tips regarding managing
the collecting impulse one strategy I
have used is to make friends with people
who share the same hobby or collection
and do regular exchanges with them so
you get the thrill of having a new item
but then when the turtle wears off you
just return it to the other owner and
you can get another new item when you
get it back all right Jo that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalist give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm or
especially looking for questions about
sex love business jobs and sleep for
five different future episodes so just
say at the beginning of your message if
your question is about that and we will
make sure it moves up to the front of
the line and if y'all live here with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus